Und ich bin sehr gespannt, ob du sie alle erkennen kannst.
Wer sie erkennt, der summe bitte diese nette Melodie in sich weiter. Auf jeden Fall seid ihr auf Fritz, ist atmet schon ganz entspannt. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das bedeutet der Chaos Computer Club ist wieder zu Gast. Heute Chaos Radio mit Tim und Pawel. Schönen guten Abend.
Das war ja parallel.
Wollen wir noch mal eins? Hallo Tim. Hallo Pawel. Hallo. Heute Chaos Radio Nummer 126. Und wie immer haben wir ein Thema, was der Chaos Computer Club sich lange und intensiv überlegt hat. Ich stehe ein kleines bisschen auf dem Schlauch, weil wir reden heute über Mac OS und die Frage, die vorhin schon diskutiert wurde und wenn man fünf Leute fragt, kriegt man sechs Antworten. Heißt es Mac OS X? Heißt es Mac OS X? Heißt es Mac OS 10? Oder Mac OS römisch 10, damit man nichts falsch macht? Da sind eure Meinungen auch gefragt. Ihr könnt natürlich gerne hier anrufen und mitdiskutieren unter 0331 70 97 110, weil dazu ist die Sendung da, dass wir miteinander reden. Und es geht um eure Erfahrungen mit Mac OS, mit dem Betriebssystem von Apple. Oder aber wenn ihr Hardcore-Windows-User seid und sagt, diesen Apfelkrempel möchte ich bitte nicht in meinem Haus haben, kann man wunderbar darüber diskutieren, über das Pro und das Contra.
Na gut.
Du bist ein konstruktiver Streit.
Ja, ein konstruktiver Streit immer.
Natürlich. Außerdem werden wir im Laufe der Sendung auch noch auf das Camp hinweisen.
Ja, das sollten wir auch alles gleich ganz am Anfang machen, weil, was vielleicht viele auch noch nicht begriffen haben, Chaosradio ist ab sofort kürzer, weil der Blue Moon kürzer ist bei Fritz. Das heißt, anstatt der etablierten drei Stunden werden wir nur zwei Stunden dummes Zeug schmetzen.
Jetzt mal dein Mikrofon ein Stückchen höher knirschtest, damit du auch quasi nicht drunter, sondern die alten Knochen.
Okay. Hauptsache, ich kann noch meinen Bildschirm lesen. Das geht gerade so. Wollen wir den Spucknapf ein bisschen nach oben drehen?
So was gibt es hier alles im Radio. Das heißt Pop-Schutz oder Plop-Schutz, wenn man den wegmacht.
Pop-Schutz klingt so uneinständig oder irgendwie bieder.
Darum geht es aber eigentlich mit Mac OS X1010.
Genau, da kommen wir gleich hin, aber bevor wir das wieder vergessen, weil uns die Zeit davon rennt, und das könnte ja heute wirklich passieren, müssen wir natürlich erst mal darauf hinweisen, was als nächstes passiert. Und als nächstes gibt es das Chaos-Communication-Camp, das ist die 5-Tage Open Air Hacker-Treffen-Veranstaltung des Chaos Computer Club.
Auf einer der schönsten Locations oder Gegenden, wo man das hier in der Gegend machen kann, nämlich dem Flughafenmuseum in Niederfino.
Ja, kennst du das?
Ja, da gibt es jedes Jahr, total unnördig, da gibt es jedes Jahr eins der schönsten Hot-Rot-Treffen. Und zwar Anfang Juli, das Rot-Rot-Rot-Paradise. Alte Autos, große Motoren, viel Rock'n'Roll. Und dann wird es auch ein bisschen nördig, dann gibt es das Race 61, da wird ein Viertelmeilen Beschleunigungsrennen gefahren, allerdings nur bis Baujahr 61. Das heißt, da kommen irgendwelche Totalverrückten, die sich alte Geräte zusammengesteckt haben und die fahren dann einfach Rennen gegeneinander. Und rundherum spielen Bands, fantastische Veranstaltungen und dieses Flughafenmuseum ist wirklich ein alter Militärflughafen, auf dem stehen Maschinen à la Colère, von einer IL-62 über eine IL-18, also eine Propellermaschine bis hin zur MIG-21. Man kann theoretisch in jedes dieser Flugzeuge rein, an jedem Knopf mal drehen, überall drauf treten. Man kann in einem Hufschrauber sitzen, man kann in diesen Hangarsabend sitzen, das ist also sowohl Sonnen- als auch Regen geschützt. Und es gibt ein Wäldchen rundherum und einen schöneren Ort für verrückten Veranstaltungen gibt es in einer Nähe kaum, nördlich von Berlin, etwa 40 Minuten zu fahren Richtung Eberswalde.
Ja, perfekt, hätte ich jetzt nicht besser zusammenfassen können.
So, also da ist das.
Es ist wirklich ein schönes Gelände und es wird dann halt CCC-typisch mit entsprechender Infrastruktur ausgelobt. Also da kommt dickes Glasfaserkabel raus und dann ist da viel Internet und WLAN, natürlich diese ganzen Standards. Aber was viel interessanter ist, als dass es da auch Internet gibt, ist natürlich, dass da Leute aus aller Welt zusammenkommen. Das ist also wirklich eine internationale Veranstaltung. Großteil des Programms ist dann auch auf Englisch, wie das bei unserem Kongress ja mittlerweile auch der Fall ist. Und es haben sich viele Leute angesagt. Es gibt irrwitzige Anreiseprojekte, unter anderem dieses Hackers on a Plane, wo sich eine Gruppe die Woche vorher noch in Las Vegas vergnügt, auf der DEFCON. Das ist diese in den USA sehr populäre Hacker-Veranstaltung. Und dann setzen sich danach alle ins Flugzeug, kaufen sozusagen ein Kombiticket für beide Veranstaltungen, inklusive Flug nach Europa und wieder zurück und landen dann halt direkt hier in Fino und haben hier Spaß.
Auf der Landebahn direkt.
Das muss ich gleich ein bisschen... Ich bin ja diesmal organisatorisch nicht eingebunden. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die Genehmigung haben oder ob sie über Berlin fliegen. Auf jeden Fall fliegen sie nach Berlin. Ob sie direkt nach Fino fliegen, weiß ich nicht. Aber das werde ich sicherlich noch im Laufe der Sendung von irgendjemand mitgeteilt bekommen. Wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, das Camp wird stattfinden. Es ist das dritte Camp. Wir haben das schon zweimal gemacht, in einem anderen Location. Und es wird großartig.
Und wer da nicht hinkommt, braucht einen guten Entschuldigungszettel von Mutti.
Und frühestens erst wieder in vier Jahren.
Ja, genau. Also es ist eine wirklich sehr seltene Veranstaltung. Und deswegen sollte man sich das wärmstens überlegen.
bis 16. August, ne?
8. bis 12.
Genau. Also das sind so die Kernveranstaltungstage, an denen auch Vortragsprogramm ist. Gefahrensgemäß, viele trudeln auch schon mal ein, zwei Tage früher ein. Ist ja auch bei uns immer so, dass eben die Leute, die da hinkommen, sind ja auch die Veranstaltung selbst. Das heißt, sie helfen mit. Und alles ist dadurch getragen, dass alle mit anpacken. Nur das erlaubt uns überhaupt, diese Veranstaltung auch so günstig zu machen. Ob der Eintrittspreis günstig ist, da gibt es immer viele Diskussionen. Tatsache ist, solche Veranstaltungen sind sehr teuer. Und um das überhaupt machen zu können, muss einfach der Anteil genommen werden.
Das ist klar.
Und wenn dann irgendjemand ankommt mit einem Bollerwagen, wo hinten ein Rechner drauf steht und ein Router, der dann wohl mein DSL-WLAN geht nicht, könnt ihr mal einrichten?
Ja, das ist keine User-Support-Veranstaltung, aber man kann dort auf jeden Fall Leute zu jedem Thema treffen. Also es gibt Dörfer, das Ganze ist so aufgebaut in Villages. Das ist teilweise so regional. Da gibt es das belgische Village, die sicherlich da wieder ein Panoptikum der belgischen Braukunst präsentieren. Und auch die Österreicher sind da ganz findig. Aber eben auch vor allem viele Dörfer, die sich eben bestimmten Themen zuwenden. Also so die Freifunk-Community wird wieder da sein und sich dann eben so mit offenen WLANs beschäftigen, Kryptographen und so weiter und so weiter. Liste ist lang. Es gibt dazu ein Wiki. Das Ganze findet sich unter events.ccc.de. Das brauche ich jetzt hier alles nicht wiederzugeben, wer Interesse hat.
Im ccc.de ist das, was man weitergeben und im Kopf behalten muss.
Es gibt halt dieses Events.ccc.de. Das ist so ein Webblog und dahinter noch ein Wiki, wo eben insbesondere die Veranstaltungen des Clubs immer präsentiert werden, weil das noch sehr viel umfangreicher ist, während sich www.ccc.de mehr um die eigentliche nach außen Kommunikation kammert.
Gesetzt in den Fallen, das sind die letzte Bemerkungen dazu, wenn ich irgendwie absolut keine Zeit habe zwischen dem 8. und 12. August und da nicht hinkommen kann, gibt es von euch sicherlich auch eine Art der Nachbearbeitung, wo man dann online sich nochmal die wichtigsten Dinge angucken, durchlesen, weiter beschäftigen kann.
Ja, wir dokumentieren ja immer ganz eifrig. Das wird auch dieses Mal der Fall sein. Aber das ersetzt halt eigentlich nicht die Atmosphäre vor Ort. Die ist, weiß nicht, Pavel, du warst da.
Das ist auch eine sehr visuelle Veranstaltung. Einfach mit viel Illumination und es ist einfach nett anzuschauen überhaupt. Nur, also man braucht keine Drogen zu nehmen, um irgendwie euphorisch zu werden. Es reicht, wenn man dann so über das Gelände geht, während dann so leichte Nebelschwaden dann zwischen den Leuchtstoffröhren durchziehen, während anderswo auf irgendwelche Wasserfälle mit Video projiziert wird, während an anderen Stellen dann die Dinge blinken und funkeln. Und also es ist, man sollte sich wirklich wenigstens einen Tag nehmen und hinkommen, aber am besten tatsächlich alle. Zelt einpacken.
Das ist einfach, man kann es auch schwer beschreiben.
Sich Silvesterfeuerwerk erzählen lassen ist nur halb so lustig, wie es selber gesehen zu werden.
Man kann es nicht erzählen.
Genau.
Gut, 8. bis 12. August, Camp Teil 3, events.ccc.de.
Exakt.
Hätten wir das Strich drunter, heute geht es um Mac OS.
Genau, heute geht es um Mac OS X. Und wie das immer meine Art ist, schaue ich natürlich kurz vor der Sendung, was sich in unserem tollen Chaosradio Wiki, wiki-chaos-radio-ccc.de, so getan hat. Da sind ja immer viele fleißige Hände schon am Werkeln. Ich bin jedes Mal wieder überrascht. Wie auch in so kurzer Zeit. Ich habe diese Sendung diese Nacht angekündigt und ich schaue halt jetzt drauf und es ist wieder alles irgendwie schön dokumentiert. An der Stelle noch mal Dankeschön für die Leute, die sich dort einbringen. Dort sind auch ein paar kluge Fragen gefragt worden und natürlich auch ein paar dumme Kommentare abgelassen worden. Und zwei würde ich mal kurz vorlesen, die eigentlich, was jetzt unser Thema heute betrifft, ja, eine ganze Menge Aussagen, weil der Apfel spaltet die Massen in unserer Zielgruppe. Der erste Kommentar ist ganz ehrlich, was für ein scheiß Thema heute. Ich meine, dieses proprietäre Betriebssystem aus dem Hause Apple interessiert doch niemanden. Ich denke, man hätte lieber eine Sendung über Linux machen sollen oder von mir aus über Betriebssysteme allgemein. Auf der Themenvorschlagseite waren so viele gute Themen, aber nein, man nimmt sich das Schlechteste. Werde mir die Sendung vermutlich nicht anhören, aber ich hoffe auf Besserung. Das ist so das eine Spektrum, das habe ich schon mit gerechnet, das sehen in der Tat viele Leute so. Der zweite Kommentar direkt dahinter ist, danke für dieses tolle Thema, freue mich schon auf heute Abend.
Das ist wie in Leserbriefen in der Zeitschrift, wo der eine sagt, das ist alles doof, was jeder macht, und der andere sagt, alles super. Das ist jetzt redaktionell nicht quasi ausgesucht und gegeneinander gestellt von uns, damit ihr seht, es alles ausgeglichen, sondern es steht wirklich so auf dem Wiki. Genau, zu deiner Frage, wie man das ausspricht, Mac OS X, Mac OS X, Mac OS X, Mac OS 10, Mac OS 10.
Es gibt da eine offizielle Sprachregelung, die Apple mal ausgegeben hat, und sie heißt Mac OS 10. Interessiert sich das? Damit wollen sie halt sozusagen auch die zehnte Version und so weiter. Aber inoffiziell nennt jeder das so, wie er meint, und das werden wir auch hier bunt durcheinander kommunizieren. Ja, worum geht es uns? Wir wollten mal ein bisschen klar machen, was Mac OS X eigentlich ist und wo es herkommt, und damit auch mal so ein bisschen unterstreichen, welche Bedeutung das heutzutage hat. So ein Vorfeld haben wir ja schon eifrig diskutiert.
Und damit auch zu erklären, warum man eigentlich zwei Stunden lang über Mac OS reden muss.
Zunächst einmal ist es so, heutzutage haben wir es in der Computerwelt mit drei Betriebssystemen zu tun, die von Relevanz sind. Es gibt natürlich sehr viel mehr, und da gibt es sicherlich Leute, die auch noch anderer Meinung sind. Aber ich denke, es ist schon ziemlich deutlich, heutzutage haben Bedeutung Windows, Linux und Mac OS X. Und je nachdem, wohin man schaut, ist diese Bedeutung sehr unterschiedlich groß.
Welche Branche da angesprochen wird?
Welche Branche, welcher Benutzer vor allem auch, weil es geht ja nicht immer nur um Firmen, auch so ein bisschen, wie man da eigentlich rangeht, ob man ein neuer Benutzer ist oder ob man schon immer dabei ist, welche Tradition man selber hat und eben auch, was man selber sozusagen von so einem System erwartet. Und häufig hat man natürlich diesen Punkt bei Apple, na ja, das ist ja das, was sich gut benutzen lässt. Das sind so die klassischen Statements dazu. Bloß das Wissen darüber, was es nun eigentlich ist und wo der Unterschied ist, ist doch relativ gering. Und das wollten wir jetzt halt mal ein bisschen unterstreichen.
Falls ihr übrigens jetzt am Radio sitzen und euch den Kopf gerade so wicke, dann seid ihr in guter Gesellschaft, weil ich bin auch jemand, ich benutze Computer schon sehr lange. Mir ist es eigentlich relativ wurscht vorrauf und ich bin ein totaler Apple-Idiot. Ich habe noch nie wirklich ernsthaft auf einem Mac gearbeitet und finde von daher diese ganze Geschichte heute auch extrem spannend. Und versuche auch immer wieder, wenn es sehr technisch wird oder wenn Fragen auftauchen, die blöde Hand zu heben und zu sagen, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Und das könnt ihr natürlich gerne auch machen. Aber was im Betrieb ist es denn jetzt, weiß ich noch. Das ist das, was mich sozusagen den Computer benutzen lässt. Also die Oberfläche, die mir dann im Endeffekt Dinge zur Verfügung stellt, mit denen ich arbeiten kann.
Die Oberfläche, aber auch die Unterfläche. Also vor allem ist es das, was überhaupt diesen Computer erstmal zu einem Computer macht.
Weil ansonsten sind es lauter Drähte und Plastik.
Und wenn man ihn einschaltet, muss ja irgendwas erstmal aktiv werden, bevor man selber aktiv werden kann. Und es muss halt auch irgendetwas geben, wo Anwendungsentwickler, also Firmen, die mir jetzt Software verkaufen wollen oder vielleicht auch kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen wollen, die darauf, die müssen auf irgendwas gemeinsam aufsetzen, weil sonst wird das eben nix. Von daher sind Betriebssysteme nach wie vor ein wichtiges Thema, auch wenn man sie am liebsten eigentlich nicht sieht. Also umso weniger so ein System einem in die Quere kommt, umso besser. Und das ist natürlich ein hohes Ziel. Und bisher ist es eigentlich auch keinem so richtig gelungen. Also es gibt kein perfektes Betriebssystem und das wird es auch nie geben. Aber es gibt natürlich bestimmte Systeme, die bestimmte Märkte besser bedienen können, als das eben andere tun.
Da hätte ich mal was vorbereitet.
So Sumi. Ja, Pawel ist ja auch schon... Genau.
Na ja, ich habe 1984 angefangen, für den Mac-Software zu entwickeln. Hab dann auch natürlich lange so Mac OS als mein Hauptbetriebssystem, was ich zum Arbeiten benutzt habe, bis 99. Etwa da hatte ich dann die Schnauze voll und habe mir dann ein Microsoft Windows PC gekauft. Und es war dann erst mal eine große Befreiung. Ich bin aber jetzt seit es die Intel Macs gibt, dann wieder zurückgekehrt und habe jetzt wieder, ja, OS X. Ich sage immer OS X, das ist kurz, da stolpert man nicht so drüber. Und ja, eigentlich braucht man doch alle drei Betriebssysteme tatsächlich. Ich habe sie auch alle auf meinem Rechner. Das Schöne ist, dass man auf den neuen Intel Macs jetzt auch wirklich alle drei Betriebssysteme fahren kann. Das ist auch noch mal ein ganz gutes Argument, was vielleicht auch man nicht so denken würde. Ich habe gerade mal die letzten Zahlen vom Marktanteil angesehen.
Oh, der Marktanteil, welchen denn?
Na ja, von Windows, Linux und OS X auf der PC-Plattform. Und interessanterweise liegt OS X bei 6% Marktanteil gegenüber 0, 6% von Linux.
Aber welchen Markt meinst du denn jetzt?
PC's allgemein.
Du meinst neu verkaufte Geräte? Du redest nicht von der Installed Base.
Doch, es ist hier der Desktop Market Share, so wie ich das hier sehe. Und der Punkt ist...
Moment, ganz kurz, Installed Base, Desktop Market Share.
Also mit diesem Marktanteil, da wird immer viel Schindluder getrieben. Man kann natürlich einfach sagen, okay, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie viele Computer werden so verkauft und dann schauen wir mal, welches Betriebssystem da drauf ist. Und dann haben wir unseren Marktanteil jeden Quartal immer wieder frisch. So, das sagt aber nur davon aus, wie viele neu verkauft werden. Das sagt nicht, wie lange ein Gerät in Benutzung bleibt und wann sozusagen ein Neukauf, ein altes ersetzt oder sozusagen ein neues hinzukommt. Und von der Installed Base, also von der installierten Basis spricht man eben, wenn man wirklich jetzt mal schaut, was ist denn die durchschnittliche Lebensdauer eines solchen Gerätes und aber auch so ein bisschen, wie viele Leute benutzen diesen einen Computer eigentlich gleichzeitig, also wie viele Personen bezieht sich das. Und da ergibt sich dann meistens schon ein ganz anderes Bild. Also Macs werden zum Beispiel in der Regel deutlich länger benutzt als Windows-PCs. Also Windows-PCs ist eigentlich nach zwei bis drei Jahren in der Regel werden die Systeme ersetzt in Firmen und auch zu Hause. Während Macs eigentlich im Schnitt es schon gut auf vier bis fünf Jahre bringen. Und das macht natürlich schon mal eine ganze Menge aus.
Der eben gesprochen Punkt dieser Wechsel zu den Intel-Chips, also da ging ja ein großer Aufschrei, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, durch auch das Lager der Apple-User und der Apple-Fan-Gemeinde, dass Apple plötzlich quasi die Chips benutzt, die der Erzfeind auch benutzt hat. Und eine Frage, die auch im Wiki auftaucht und die sich Leute jetzt immer wieder auch stellen, ist warum ein Mac benutzen, wenn die mittlerweile quasi den Prozessor benutzen, den die Gegenseite auch benutzt. Da gibt es ja eigentlich offensiv keinen Grund mehr.
Ja, man benutzt ja nicht den Prozessor, man benutzt ja das Betriebssystem.
Siehst du, da steigt mein technisches Fachwissen schon aus.
Ich meine, benutzt du deinen Prozessor?
Keine Ahnung.
Na ja, wieso nicht? Du klickst auf irgendwas rum und ob das nun irgendwie auf einem Power-PC läuft oder auf einem Intel, ist dir eigentlich ziemlich schwierig.
Ja, aber die Frage war doch, das Herzstück sozusagen, der Prozessor, ist doch dann der eine oder andere, ne?
Ja, das war dann auch immer natürlich... Nein, nein, das ist schon richtig. Das ist eine berechtigte Frage. Das war, dieses PowerPC-Mythos war halt natürlich auch immer so ein Mythos, so wo man dann meinte, weil man jetzt mit den hohen Gigahertz-Zahlen nicht mithalten konnte. Und das immer so wie das PS-Argument gewesen ist, hat man dann aber argumentiert, ja, keine Ahnung. Aber unser Hubraum ist halt größer beim PowerPC. Unsere Befehle machen halt größere Schritte als die anderen. Und ja, es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass jede Prozessor-Generation, die gebaut wird, immer mehr Geld verschlingt. Da gehen also Milliarden mittlerweile an Entwicklungskosten rein und da ist einfach nicht so viel Platz auf der Welt, um mehrere Dinge da voranzutreiben. Und deswegen war es einfach so, dass Intel dort in der Lage war, einfach die schnellsten Prozessoren tatsächlich irgendwann zu bauen und alle anderen dort nicht mitgekommen sind.
Also nicht nur Intel, sondern auch alle anderen Firmen, die sozusagen kompatibel zu Intel sind. Da gibt es ja auch noch AMD und diverse andere Anbieter. Da hat sich einfach ein riesiger Markt aufgetan, während Apple eben mit Motorola und IBM ins Bett gesprungen ist vor einigen Jahren. Und damals, als es anfing mit der PowerPC-Generation, da war das halt auch tatsächlich so, dass die große Vorteile hatten. Die waren Stromspanier. Wir konnten ganz früh Laptops bauen, sehr kleine, die nicht heiß geworden sind. Da war mit einer Intel-Plattform überhaupt nicht dran zu denken.
Hokel sagt, wir sollen auf Mac OS kommen.
Ja, kommen wir. Richtig. Und die technische Plattform ist eigentlich egal mittlerweile, weil mir geht es ja darum, ein System zu haben. Deswegen reden wir auch über das Betriebssystem Mac OS X und ob das nun da oder da oder da läuft, ist eigentlich egal.
Wobei auch im WIGI war natürlich auch die Frage, welche Rolle spielen in Betriebssysteme heutzutage eigentlich überhaupt sind die überhaupt noch so wichtig. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass sie etwas weniger wichtig werden als noch vor ein paar Jahren, weil natürlich sehr viel auch über das Web mittlerweile läuft und weil man sehr viel im Browser herumklickt oder in seinem E-Mail-Client. Also bei mir ist es auch so, dass ich vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ein Drittel der Zeit letztendlich in einem Browser-Fenster unterwegs bin. Und da ist es fast egal, auf welchem Betriebssystem das passiert, aber eben nur fast.
Ja eben, eben nur fast. Weil am Ende stellt man dann doch wieder fest, dass einem der eigene Rechner doch am liebsten ist und man dort eben auch alle Kommunikationskanäle zusammenlaufen, die eigenen Daten bearbeitet werden und es eben schon wichtig ist, ob man mit seinem Computer einfach klarkommt oder nicht. Und an der Stelle entscheidet sich irgendwie auch das Rennen. Jetzt wurde es mit der Hardware im Prinzip, also im Prinzip keinen Unterschied mehr darstellt. Man kann ja nicht Mac OS X auf jedem beliebigen Rechner laufen lassen, sondern eben nur auf Rechnern von Apple, zumindest legal. Illegal ist es möglich, aber nicht wirklich reizvoll. Das ist eigentlich eher nur so eine technische Herausforderung, aber man hat da eigentlich relativ wenig davon. Jetzt entscheiden halt andere Sachen. Also jetzt gibt es nicht mehr dieses Prozessorrennen und habe ich einen Megahertz mehr oder weniger, weil was nützt mir denn dieses Megahertz mehr, wenn die Software nur halb so langsam läuft? Ja, dann habe ich davon auch nichts. Und Apple versucht sich eben im Desktop-Bereich vor allem einfach durch einen ganz anderen Ansatz zu unterscheiden, wie sie an den Benutzer herantreten. Einfach vom Benutzer ausgehen und nicht von der Software ausgehen. Windows ist ein extrem, und auch Linux, ist eine extrem technokratische Systeme, wo einfach sehr viel definiert dadurch ist, wie die Programmierer die Welt sehen. Das merkt man schon an den Fehlermeldungen. Das schaut man sich an. Und ja, allgemeine Schutzverletzung. Sagt dir das was? Sagt dir nix. Und das ist eben das, was wenige in der Branche auch wirklich verstehen, dass die Leute eigentlich sich weniger für die Giga-Herze interessieren, als dafür, was sie mit so einem System auch wirklich erreichen können. Vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zum Werdegang von OS X, um mal klarzumachen, was sich da eigentlich auch für eine dramatische Entwicklung abgezeichnet hat. Weil ein Betriebssystem lässt sich immer eine ganze Menge festmachen. Wenn man es genau nimmt, gibt es nämlich heute eigentlich nur noch zwei Betriebssysteme. Eigentlich gibt es nämlich nur noch Windows und UNIX. UNIX ist aber nicht ein System, sondern UNIX ist so ein riesiger Garten, so eine riesige Familie mit Neffen und Großtanten und irgendwie entfernten Verwandtern und verschwägerten Systemen, die sich alle irgendwie ähnlich sind, aber dann am Ende doch extreme Unterschiede aufweisen. Also auch Linux ist ein von UNIX abgegucktes System, ist dann komplett neu geschrieben worden, aber ist eigentlich ein UNIX-System. Aber auch Mac OS X hat im Herzen dieses UNIX. Und das ist eigentlich fast mit das älteste Betriebssystem, was derzeit überhaupt noch im Einsatz ist, weil das eben Anfang der 70er Jahre entwickelt wurde und bis heute so sein Leben fortgesetzt hat. Und dann gibt es halt noch Windows. Ja, und Apple hat aber nicht so angefangen, sondern die ersten Macintoshes in den 80er Jahren, also als der Apple Macintosh da mit großem Brimborium 84 vorgestellt wurde, hatte halt sein eigenes System, Mac OS, wie man ja auch heute noch zu dem aktuellen System sagt. Aber Mac OS ist sozusagen der Vorgänger von Mac OS X.
Und es war ein Assembler geschrieben, also auf Systemebene.
Und es musste noch mit viel weniger RAM auskommen, ganz klar, wie die Computer eben damals waren. Aber auch da haben sie schon eben gesagt, wir gehen jetzt vom Benutzer aus und wir bauen jetzt etwas, was sich leicht bedienen lässt. Und wir haben dann eine Maus und wir haben einen grafischen Bildschirm, wir haben Fenster und wir haben Button zum Anklicken. Das war neu. Das hatte einfach noch keiner in so einem fertigen Computer eingebaut. Es gab halt ähnliche Systeme im Forschungsbereich, aber so als Commodity-Produkt, dass man sich das so kaufen konnte, gab es das eben nicht. Das hat dann lange gedauert. Erst so Mitte der 90er Jahre kam dann eben Microsoft mit seinem Windows auf und hat eben diese ganzen von Apple etablierten Konzepte kopiert und, naja, so adaptiert und so sah alles so ein bisschen so ähnlich aus, war aber nicht unbedingt immer das Gleiche. Und auch alle anderen Systeme machen halt heute mittlerweile das, sodass man sagen kann, okay, ein Computer, das hat so Fenster und Buttons und darauf hat man sich jetzt so ein bisschen geeinigt. Aber es gibt dann halt trotzdem noch Unterschiede. Na ja, Apple war dann ziemlich, wie soll ich sagen?
Zerstritten.
Zerstritten, aber vor allem erst mal extrem selbstherrlich. Also so Anfang der 90er Jahre waren sie einfach die totalen Kings. Ja, Personalkomputer erfunden und Revolution und die Maus überhaupt. Und uns kopieren ja alle nur und wir sind sowieso die Besten und haben irgendwie extrem viel Rechner verkauft und viel Geld verdient. Und fühlten sich also total toll, haben dann aber mehr als nur einen Trend verschlafen. Und das der größte Fehler, den sie gemacht haben, war, dass sie ihr Betriebssystem haben verrotten lassen. Dieses Mac OS, so gut es am Anfang gewesen war und so viele innovative Ideen drin waren, war einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß und hat also viele Anforderungen, die man so hatte, was weiß ich, dass Software vor sich selbst geschützt wird und nicht irgendwie ein abstürzendes Programm den ganzen Computer mit nach unten bringt oder dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig auf so ein System arbeiten können oder zumindest im Wechsel. Das gab es halt irgendwie alles gar nicht. Und dann haben sie irgendwie hier ein Projekt gestartet, da ein Projekt gestartet, noch ein Projekt gestartet, noch mal ein Projekt gestartet, um die nächste Iteration und Revolution und so weiter. Und dann haben sie es wieder verworfen und wieder ein neues Projekt gestartet. Und irgendwann standen sie da, wurden von Windows 95 komplett links überholt, rechts überholt und hatten kein Betriebssystem. Hatten dazu noch eine völlig verkackte Hardware-Politik gefahren. Und 1995 haben eigentlich wenige Leute auch nur einen Pfifferling darauf gegeben, dass es Apple in ein paar Jahren noch geben wird. Das war sozusagen das Ende von Apple und dann war es vorbei. Aber es kam anders.
Wir können auch ganz kurz jetzt eine Zäsur machen, sagen, da kam auch anders, die Nachrichten machen wir danach weiter. Eva, uns jetzt verfummeln. Matthias, ist für dich total in Ordnung? Ich könnte auch noch An Apple a Day.
Gibt es denn überhaupt Nachrichten?
Na selbstverständlich gibt es Nachrichten.
Schon wieder was passiert?
Na selbstverständlich.
Oh, jetzt kommt der Nachrichtssprecher. Oh, mit einem weißen Gewand.
Die Zeit rennt. Ein Viertel von Blue Moon haben wir jetzt schon mit...
Und wir müssen uns schneller reden.
Weniger und schneller.
Wir kriegen das in jedem Fall auf die Reihe. So, bereiten Sie es sind? Ja, fantastisch.
Kurz präsentiert das IFA Sommergarten Open Air. Mit Freundeskreis. Mit Bounce Sound. Das IFA Sommergarten Open Air. Samstag, 1. September. Ab 17 Uhr im IFA Sommergarten auf dem Messegelände Berlin.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Das IFA Sommergarten Open Air. Und das hört man.
Halb 11.
Fritz.info.
Mit Matthias Kerkov.
Ein weiteres Team steigt bei der Tour de France aus. Der französische Rennstall Cofidis hört auf, weil einer seiner Fahrer, der Italiener Christian Morini, positiv auf Testosteron getestet wurde. Der 34-Jährige wurde heute kurz nach der Zieleinfahrt verhaftet. Gestern war das Astana-Team wegen des Dopings eines Kapitäns Sevino Kunow ausgestiegen. Die vermeintliche Entführung eines deutschen Journalisten in Afghanistan hat für Verwirrung gesorgt. Jetzt scheint klar, es handelte sich um einen Dänischen Reporter afghanischer Abstammung. Der Mann konnte den Geiselnehmern in letzter Minute entkommen. Im Streit um mehr Geld haben die Lokführer mit ihrer Urabstimmung begonnen. Die Gewerkschaft rechnete mit, dass ihre Mitglieder mit großer Mehrheit für einen Streik stimmen. Seit heute bekämpfen sich beide Seiten auch vor Gericht. Die Bahn will Streiks verbieten lassen. Die Lokführer gehen gegen Einschüchterungsversuche der Bahn vor. Der FC Bayern München hat zum siebten Mal das Finale um den Liga-Pokal erreicht. Der Rekord-Chämchen besiegte soeben im Halbfinale den ersatzgeschwächten deutschen Meister VfB Stuttgart mit 2 zu 0. Nachts in Nordbrandenburg, teils wolkig, aber kaum noch Schauer. Sonst meist locker oder gering bewölkt und trocken. Abkühlung auf 13 bis 14 Grad. Morgen heiter im Tagesverlauf von der Uckermark und vom Hafenland Wolkiger. Und erst abends einzelne Schauer möglich, vorher aber durchweg trocken. Die Höchstwerte zwischen 26 bis 28 in Berlin 27 Grad. Wir haben keine Meldungen zum Verkehr, wünschen eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1? Dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Aber ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe. Und ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich das gesehen habe.
Juli 2007, Chaosradio Nummer 126 mit Tim Pavel und mein Name ist Jakob Kranze, grüße euch. Tim hat gerade eine höchst interessante Einführung in die Geschichte von Mac OS gegeben. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht in voller epischer Breite machen. Und mit dem Macintosh ging das irgendwie auch lange Zeit ziemlich gut. Bis dann halt aber großer Stress entstand. Und dann wurde halt Steve Jobs auch ausgeschmissen.
Der Mac war erst mal ein totaler Flop. Das kommt halt hinzu. Also da hat halt der Apple 2 die ganze Zeit das Geld verdient, um die ersten Jahre, wo der Mac einfach nicht lief, um ihnen drüber weg zu helfen. Und zum Dank dafür, also da hatte sich halt Steven Wozniak auch drum gekümmert, wurden die Apple 2 Jungs noch geprügelt und links liegen lassen und schlecht bezahlt. Aber die haben das ganze Geld reingebracht. Also es hat lange gedauert, bis es mit dem Mac wirklich geklappt hat. Und durch die ganzen Reibereien muss ich sagen, Steve Jobs war damals auch ein ziemliches Arschloch. Das ist also biografisch vielfach verbirgt, so wie man sich einen Arschloch vorstellt. Insofern war das auch nur konsequent, dass sie ihn irgendwann an den Gang getan haben, weil er nur intrigiert und es war böse.
Es kann halt keinen neben ihm geben. Das ist irgendwie sein Problem damals gewesen.
Dafür feiert er. Er lässt sich heute feiern und wird gefeiert als der neue CIS-DES. Aber wir wollen hier weder Personenkult betreiben, noch den Apfel in höchste Höhen schieben. Wir wollen einfach nur reden, worum es geht.
Ja, aber die ganze Geschichte ist dann nach wie vor sehr eng mit ihm verbunden. Weil er ist dann weggegangen und hat eine neue Firma gegründet und die hieß NeXT. Und hat einen neuen Computer gebaut, der auch sehr schick war, schwarz, eben den NeXT, und hat ein eigenes Betriebssystem bekommen. NeXTStep. Und das hat er eben ganz, also Steve Jobs, die ganze Firma hat halt gesagt, das ist irgendwie das, wohin es geht. Das ist sozusagen die Zukunft der Software.
War im Übrigen auch ein ziemlicher Flop der ganze Rechner. Also er hat da aus seinem Privatvermögen über die Jahre weg, also er hat da ein paar Hundert Millionen Dollar verbrannt, eigenes Geld und Investorengeld. Und NeXT lief halt nie. Also die Hardware, das hat sich nie gerechnet. Die Maschinen flogen einfach nicht. Ich meine, er hatte auch ein Wettbewerbsverbot damals. Er dürfte nicht in denselben Markt rein mit den Geräten. Deswegen wollte er so den Universitätsmarkt. Das hatten sie ihm erlaubt, aber das hat halt nicht funktioniert.
Also es hat nicht im großen Stil funktioniert. Er hat natürlich durchaus dort schon gemacht. Unter anderem wurde das World Wide Web auf einem NeXT-Computer gefunden. Also der Rechner war halt einfach ein NeXT-Rechner.
Im Übrigen gab es noch eine zweite Firma, kurz bevor wir dann tatsächlich auch zu SX kommen. Es spielt auch eine Rolle, also er hat dann halt auch Pixar als zweite Firma gehabt.
Sind das die mit den Trickfilmen?
Genau, die dann jetzt von, also da gibt es dann nämlich später noch eine interessante Parallele. Aber Pixar hatte er halt dann günstig von George Lucas abgekauft, weil der sich gerade hat scheiden lassen und seine Frau viel Geld brauchte. Und das war von den drei Firmen diejenige, an der sein Herz am wenigsten hing. Deswegen hat Steve Jobs, die zum Sportpreis von 15 Millionen Dollar damals schießen können, hat dann aber sicherlich auch noch ein paar hundert Millionen reingebuttert. Und eigentlich stand er aber so Ende der 90er. Also beide Firmen liefen nicht. Er stand eigentlich kurz vor dem totalen Bankrott mit all seinen Firmen und all seinen Unternehmungen. Nichts lief.
Und dann kam alles anders.
Und dann kam alles anders. Dann kam halt die große Krise bei Apple, die dann erst mal dazu führte, dass der aktuelle Chef Herr Spindler gefeuert wurde, weil er das ganz offensichtlich nicht auf die Reihe bekommen hat. Ist ja eigentlich Deutscher gewesen oder hat der Deutsche hinter v. Fahnen? Ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Wie auch immer. Er hat diese ganze Hardware-Strategie und Betriebssystemstrategie einfach vergeigt. Das war halt auch so ein Techniker, netter Mensch, aber irgendwie den Blick hat er halt nicht gehabt. Und die anderen Leute, die bei Apple das sagen hatten, das waren dann halt alles nur so Marketing-Hinies, die irgendwie versucht haben, dann die anderen zu kopieren. Und dann waren Macintoshes, waren halt langweilige graue Boxen, die eigentlich auch nicht toller aussahen und alles war irgendwie scheiße und ist stank. Naja, und dann hatten sie die große Krise, haben sich einen neuen CEO rein geholt von National Semi-Konductor, Jill Amelio, so ein Sanierer, der eigentlich zwar auch von all dem nichts verstand, aber Apple irgendwie ganz toll fand und dessen einzige wirkliche anerkennenswerte Leistung war, dass er alles auf den Prüfstand gestellt hat. Dann haben sie ein Jahr lang nachgedacht. Also erst haben sie ein halbes Jahr lang nachgedacht, um dann zu verkünden, dass sie noch ein halbes Jahr nachdenken, weil sie immer noch nicht zu der richtigen Antwort gekommen sind.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Radio Jerewan.
Es war so, dass übrigens Steve Jobs Amelio rein geholt hat, weil er den über seine Pixar-Connections kannte. Ja, der hat ihn überredet, da reinzugehen. Und hat ihn dann allerdings auch... Also gut, sie reden noch miteinander, aber das war auch alles nicht so ganz super. Im Übrigen war es auch Amelio, der dann die iPods gestartet hat. Also das wurde dann auch Steve Jobs angerechnet, aber eigentlich hat noch Amelio den Trend gebracht. Und Jobs hat dann aber es tatsächlich geschafft, so plötzlich all die ganze Scheiße, die er am Hacken hatte, auf einmal in Gold zu verwandeln, weil bei Pixar finanzierte dann Disney ihm einen Film, Toy Story. Und ja, sein Betriebssystem, also NeXT, wurde dann von Apple gekauft, wobei das eher so eine umgekehrte Übernahme war. Also Apple hat zwar NeXT gekauft, aber die ganze Führungs-Crew von NeXT saß dann anschließend an den ganzen Apple-Schaltstellen. Dasselbe ist dann später passiert, als irgendwann nach langen, zehn Jahre langen Kämpfen hin und her Disney Pixar gekauft hat. Dann haben halt auch alle Pixar-Leute jetzt die Schaltstellen von Disney besetzt. Im Übrigen ist Steve Jobs auch an Disney der größte Anteilseigner durch dieses Ding geworden und er hat halt schon bemerkenswert ist, dass dieser Mann tatsächlich die Computerindustrie, die Musikindustrie und die Filmindustrie im Alleingang, aber durch viel Glück revolutioniert hat.
Obwohl er ein Arschloch ist, wie wir vorhin festgestellt haben.
Er hat sich ein bisschen gebessert.
Wir sind jetzt in der Geschichte dabei, dass es immer noch eine Krise gab und Sie denken nach und wir sind immer noch nicht bei Mac OS.
Doch, denn, und jetzt kommt nämlich schon der Punkt, die Entscheidung, dass Apple NeXT gekauft hat, also und sich damit sozusagen Steve Jobs wieder einverleibt hat, aber eben vor allem auch die Technologie, die seine Firma eben NeXT in den letzten zehn Jahren entwickelt hat, eingekauft hat, das war im Prinzip schon die Kernaussage, wir schmeißen Mac OS, das alte Mac OS weg und ersetzen es durch NeXTStep. Das wurde dann umbenannt, mehrere Male, das hieß dann erstmal Rhapsody und dann Bluebox, Yellowbox, tausend Namen und irgendwann mit großem Tamtam, es dauerte dann halt noch bis 2000, bis es dann wirklich rauskam, haben sie dann eben die mehrfach überarbeitete Version von diesem alten NeXTStep, was zwischendurch OpenStep hieß, als Mac OS X neu vorgestellt. Ist aber im Prinzip in seinen Wurzeln dieses NextStep-System und selbiges setzte auch schon immer auf UNIX auf. Schließen sich eben die Bögen wieder auf BSD. Genau. Und mit anderen Worten, sie hatten gar nicht ein komplett neues Betriebssystem im eigentlichen Sinne, sondern sie haben es neu lackiert und sie haben es auch so ein bisschen verschmolzen mit Mac OS. Sie haben also so die Sachen, die bei Mac OS auch wirklich ok waren, die nur darunter litten, dass der Rest so scheiße war. Sagen wir mal so einzelne Sachen wie QuickTime zum Beispiel, das man ja auch heute noch kennt. Das sind halt alles so Systeme, die aus dem alten System herauskamen, die NeXT wiederum nicht hatte. Und so kamen eben beides zusammen. Und das Ergebnis war ein Betriebssystem, was auf der einen Seite vielen Leuten doch recht bekannt vorkam, weil es irgendwie UNIX war, auf der anderen Seite aber mit so ein paar Paradigmen auch total brach. Denn die Art und Weise, wie man Programme entwickelte für NeXT, war einfach anders, als es in den 20 Jahren davor gelaufen ist. Und das ist eben auch das, was heute, oder das ist zumindest eine der Sachen, die bei Mac OS X oder Ten oder wie es auch immer heißen mag, den großen Unterschied ausmacht. Die Qualität und die Art und Weise, wie dort Software entwickelt wird. Ja, jetzt kommen wir zum kontroversen Teil, oder?
Also, die Art und Weise begeistert mich, muss ich sagen, nicht unbedingt, aber das Ergebnis ist ganz in Ordnung. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass Mac OS, auch in der Form von OS X, wesentlich weniger Stolpersteine bietet. Es ist vor allem visueller, viel aufgeräumter. Es beleidigt nicht so das Auge wie Windows XP.
Wobei auch das eine Geschmacksfrage ist, ob es das Auge beleidigt oder nicht.
Nein, es ist keine Geschmacksfrage. Ich meine, die Tatsache, dass die meisten Gestalter beispielsweise das ganze beruflich auch tun, da hat Mac OS aus vielen Gründen, aber vor allem, weil eben der Hauptgrund glaube ich, warum Gestalter Mac OS benutzen, ist gar nicht so sehr aus technischen Gründen, sondern weil sie es nicht ertragen, auf einen Windows-Desktop zu schauen, ohne dass es ihnen übel wird.
Ja, okay, aber das da glaube ich auch, dass da viel persönliche Befindlichkeit dazu gehört, wenn man irgendwie, also jeder von uns wird mehr oder weniger an einem Computer arbeiten oder damit zu tun haben. Ich kann jetzt immer noch sagen, das Blau gefällt mir nicht oder mir gefällt das eine oder das andere grafisch nicht, aber das ist eine persönliche Befindlichkeit, das hat ja noch nichts mit der wirklichen Funktionalität der Maschine zu tun, also wirklich, um damit zu arbeiten und wie komfortabel ist es. Übrigens ein Punkt, an dem ihr gerne euch einklinken und mitdiskutieren könnt, 0331 70 97 110, das ist eine Sendung, in der man anrufen und mitdiskutieren kann, wir sitzen hier nicht und halten eine Laudatio auf Apple, das ist nicht der Weg, in den es gehen sollte, nur so nebenbei.
Also so ein Betriebssystem, das ist auch ein bisschen wie eine Wohnung. Ich meine, da gucke ich die ganze Zeit drauf, das heißt, das ist jetzt nicht nur eine Frage der Technik, Du kannst auch sagen, ich habe meine Wohnung, das ist meine Tür, da schlafe ich fertig. Aber es hat auch was mit Behaglichkeit zu tun und das Problem ist...
Kaufst du bei Möbelhypna oder bei Ikea oder bei Liniere Se?
Bau ich selber.
Brauchst du selber, dann musst du Linus benutzen.
Genau, und das Problem ist aber, wo der Vergleich mit der Wohnung natürlich aufhört, ist, das wäre so, als wenn man sich nur entscheiden könnte, in drei verschiedene Wohnungen vom Grundstil einzuziehen und der Großteil der Möbel und Sachen, die da drin steht, ich könnte also meine Windows-Wohnung einziehen und egal, was ich tue, die sieht so, das ist halt dann immer eine Windows-Wohnung und ja, da mag man einfach.
Aber treffen hier an dem Punkt nicht wirklich unterschiedliche Philosophien aufeinander? Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich.
Natürlich, muss ja auch Raum sein für unterschiedliche Philosophien. Aber vielleicht kann man noch mal kurz mal schauen, was macht es eigentlich aus? Was schon mal ein entscheidender Unterschied ist in der Wahrnehmung, hier im Chat, da prügeln sich jetzt auch schon wieder, wie ich das erwartet hatte.
Was prügelt sich da?
Ja, was ist denn eigentlich der Betriebssystem? Das Betriebssystem, was ist denn der Körner und so? Es gibt so verschiedene klassische Auffassungen darüber, worum sich ein Betriebssystem zu kümmern hat und worum nicht. Und die meisten UNIX-Systeme kümmern sich um herzlich wenig. Ja, da ist so ein Betriebssystem, ist so was wie, naja, irgendjemand muss sich ja darum kümmern, dass man eine Diskette lesen kann, Festplatten beschreiben kann und sich meine Dateien irgendwie speichern kann. Ja, beim Mac war es schon immer so und das ist ein großer Unterschied von OS X und auch schon dem alten Mac OS zu allen anderen Systemen. Das Betriebssystem kümmert sich um viel, viel, viel mehr als bei den anderen Systemen. Das geht auf der einen Seite natürlich unten los. Natürlich, die Hardware muss unterstützt werden. Man muss mit dem Prozessor reden, man muss mit den ganzen Geräten reden. Man muss natürlich die Schnittstellen, USB, Firewire, halt alles, was da dran ist. Das muss natürlich funktionieren, gar keine Frage. Das machen sie alle. Dann auch selbstverständlich muss den Programmierern, die für so eine Plattform entwickeln wollen, die Möglichkeit gegeben werden, dafür zu entwickeln. Da gibt es diesen sogenannten API-Ebene, also ein Application Programmer Interface, eben die Schnittstelle, wie ich mit dem Ding agiere und dann geht es los. Aber genau an der Stelle unterscheiden sich die Sachen dann doch eben frappierend, weil beim Mac diese Programmierer-Schnittstelle sehr viel mehr umfasst. Das geht dann eben bis hinein in die Dialoge, wie interagiert das GUI tatsächlich jetzt, also wie verhalten sich die Programme, wie ist die Farbe des Highlightings, das war bei Mac OS von Anfang an der Fall, dass ich irgendwie eine Farbe einstelle und dann habe ich die selbstverständlich in jedem Programm. Und wo Apple halt immer weiter war und auch immer noch weiter ist, ist, dass die Homogenität aller Programme viel ausgeprägter ist. Das heißt, klar gibt es auch Photoshop für Windows und für Mac. Und naja, es sieht auch mittlerweile ziemlich ähnlich aus. Aber das liegt auch nur daran, dass sie eben auch sehr viele Sachen nicht nutzen. Was für mich aber viel wichtiger ist, als dass Photoshop sich auf einem anderen Betriebssystem genauso bedienen lässt, ist, dass auch alle anderen Programme, die ich auf meinem Computer benutze, sich genauso verhalten. Und ich sage nicht nur ähnlich aussehen und so in etwa die gleiche bubblige Optik haben, sondern dass das Kopieren, das Selektieren, wie ich mit der Maus irgendwie ein Text irgendwo hinziehen kann, wie Highlightings funktionieren, dass einfach das ganze Verhalten, was ich bei dem einen Programm gewohnt bin, auch bei dem anderen genauso bekomme. Und da bietet Mac OS X über diesen, was man so klassisch als Betriebssystemlehr auffasst, eine Vielzahl an sogenannten Frameworks, also an fertigen Programmbibliotheken, die man als Programmierer einfach so mitbenutzt. Und nur wenn man mehr Funktionalität haben will, dann kann man das eben erweitern.
Und gut, da muss man aber sagen, da hat Windows auch durchaus ganz gut aufgeholt. Sie haben also natürlich immer auch darüber geschielt und auch gelegentlich mal das eine oder andere tatsächlich ein bisschen besser gemacht. Also kann ich sagen, jetzt ist es grundsätzlich jetzt technisch von der Bedienung her anders. Aber bei Windows ist halt die Diversität einfach viel, viel größer. Und da findet man viel, viel mehr auch ganz schreckliche Sachen, in denen man sich furchtbar verheddern kann. Beim Mac ist die Möglichkeit, sich zu verheddern oder zu verzetteln, sind auch da. Aber die sind einfach weniger. Und es gibt weniger schlechte Programme.
Okay, wobei, womit wir sind schon wieder so ein bisschen in der Krone für den Mac. Wobei sich da wirklich auch die unterschiedlichen, was hast du vorhin gesagt, die unterschiedlichen Anforderungen und die unterschiedlichen User durchaus mit ihren Bedürfnissen schlagen können, wer jetzt welches Programm braucht. Es gibt immer noch Leute, die sagen, mit dem Mac kann ich nichts anfangen, weil ich kann nicht irgendwie die Grafikkarte da einbauen, die ich gerne hätte und ich kann nicht irgendwie die Festplatte einbauen, die ich gerne hätte, weil eben nur bestimmte Komponenten in diesem Gerät gehen. Und bei einem Windows-Rechner ist es überhaupt kein Ding, kaufe ich mir eine Plastikbüchse und schiebe alles so rein, wie ich es brauche. Also Beispiel Hardcore-Gamer sind mit einem Mac wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich bedient.
Aber das sind halt die fünf Prozent des Marktes, die der Apple einfach auch nicht adressiert. Also Apple versucht gar nicht allen zu gefallen. Das ist gar nicht ihr Ziel, sondern sie konzentrieren sich auf verschiedene Märkte und jetzt eben in letzter Zeit verstärkt auf den Privatanwender. Oder wie es früher immer so schienen hieß, der Creative Individual. Würde ich mich zum Beispiel auch verstehen. Leute, die halt was schaffen wollen. Ich meine, wenn ich meinen Computer nur zum E-Mail lesen und Web surfen brauche, dann kann ich irgendwas nehmen.
Das ist egal, was das für eine Büchse ist.
Ja, dann kann ich noch ein Linux nehmen, alles wunderbar. Aber wenn ich irgendwelche Dinge erschaffen will, dann kommen mir dann halt doch sehr schnell Kleinigkeiten in die Quere. Und ich denke, dass es gerade die Kleinigkeiten sind, die die Leute wirklich nerven. Denn Kleinigkeiten hat man jeden Tag 20, 30, 40 Mal.
Okay, aber diese Aufregung über Windows und so diese Kleinigkeiten, da ist ja schon viel über geredet und gesprochen worden. Wir müssen das wahrscheinlich auch nicht in allen Details auswalzen. Interessant ist doch der Punkt, wo ist jetzt quasi die Kontroversität bei Mac OS? Weil wir reden ja weiterhin über Mac OS. Zum Beispiel, dass...
Lass mich nochmal... Also, nee, wir müssen es nicht in allen Details, aber wir müssen mal Details ansprechen. Einfach mal... Weil das ist immer sehr schwer zu vermitteln. Deswegen tasten wir uns da ja auch so ein bisschen fluffy jetzt mal ran. Wir hatten vorhin schon die Diskussion, ich will mal ein Beispiel bringen. Ich starte ein Programm. Sagen wir mal ein Textprogramm, um es ganz einfach zu machen. Da tippe ich dann so meinen Text und dann speicher ich die Datei ab. Und dann heißt die irgendwie foo.txt. Und dann beende ich mein Programm. Und dann benenne ich diese Datei um oder ich schiebe sie in irgendeinen Ordner. Und dann starte ich mein Programm. Und dann schaut dieses Programm nach den Dateien, die ich zuletzt erstellt habe. Sowas will man ja haben, so Recent Documents oder sowas. Man muss ja nicht unbedingt immer wieder alles machen. Ich weiß auch vielleicht nicht genau, wie die Datei hieß. Aber ich weiß, ich habe ja da vor einer Stunde eine Datei erzeugt. Warum soll sich das Programm nicht merken? Wenn ich die Datei jetzt umbenannt habe oder irgendwo hingeschoben habe, bin ich unter Windows, unter Linux komplett aufgeschmissen. Auf dem Mac geht das einfach. Weil er weiß, wo die Datei ist. Weil die gibt es ja noch. Die heißt zwar anders und die ist irgendwo anders, aber er weiß, was die Datei ist. Während die anderen Systeme es halt nur über den Dateinamen machen. Und dann hat man schon wieder diesen 10 Minuten meines Lebens gespart. Und dann geht es so weiter. Und dann habe ich mir wieder 10 Minuten meines Lebens gespart, weil zwei Programme gleichzeitig laufen. Selbstverständlich gleichzeitig Turn ausgeben können. Das ist bei Windows auch noch nicht so lange normal. Ich rede jetzt nicht nur von Sachen, die jetzt heute unbedingt aktuell sind, sondern wie ich es so über die Jahre erlebt habe. Und es sind immer diese Kleinigkeiten. Und 10 Kleinigkeiten am Tag können mich einfach schon mal drei Stunden Ärger kosten. Und drei Stunden Ärger pro Tag ist mir zu teuer. Will ich nicht. Ich will ein System, das einfach funktioniert und was vor allem die Dinge einfach so tut, wie sie sein.
Ja, OS X macht auch genug Ärger. Aber wie gesagt, weniger. Weniger, es ist robuster und man kann, muss ich jetzt sagen, man kann es tatsächlich benutzen, aber man kann auf Windows nicht völlig verzichten. Und aber so nach meinem Umstieg jetzt ist es so, dass ich etwa 97, weit über 90, 95 Prozent der Zeit nur mit OS X unterwegs bin. Und das Schöne ist, ich kann das Windows einfach nebenher starten. Ich brauche da nicht raus, ich brauche meinen Computer nicht umbooten. So mit Parallels kann man halt einfach mein Windows läuft einfach mit zwischendrin. Und wenn ich es ab und zu mal brauche, ist es halt da. Und ja, es geht. Also man kann, man kann damit arbeiten. Und Tim auch meinte tatsächlich, PowerPoint ist so ein Thema, wenn man mal eine Präsentation macht und es fängt an zu flackern und zu klickern und beim Scrollen hakelts und sowas hat man dann beispielsweise mit Keynote nicht. Und das sind so für mich die Gründe, warum ich das benutze.
Klickern beim Abspielen meinst du?
Naja, beim Erstellen. Man schaltet einfach auf die nächste Seite um und das ist unter Windows und das datet sich ab und ohne Ende. Aber generell merkt man schon an vielen Stellen auch, dass doch nicht so viel Geld und Arbeit und Zeit und so viele Benutzer tatsächlich mit Mac OS arbeiten. Das heißt, es hat auch einfach seine Schwächen. Und beispielsweise Performance ist nicht unbedingt eine Stärke. Kannst du das... Also die Geschwindigkeit, also beispielsweise Zugriffe auf bestimmte Arten von Festplatten etwa. So, da hatte ich gewisse Probleme, da habe ich manche Dinge nachgemessen. Und da ist, weil ich halt alle drei Betriebssysteme auf demselben Rechner fahren kann, kann man halt natürlich sehr gut vergleichen. Und da gab es durchaus Fälle, wo dann OS X einfach zehnmal langsamer als Linux und Windows funktioniert.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diesen Database-Test, der vor so einem Jahr im Gespräch war. Da gab es dann auch so mit MySQL und so weiter so eine beliebte Datenbank oder UNIX. Die lief dann halt auch. Dann hat jemand den Benchmark gemacht und festgestellt, das ist ja zehnmal so langsam. Dann gab es auch eine Riesendiskussion, wie langsam doch OS X ist, weil hier 100.000 Datensätze geschrieben, alles total langsam. Dann ging das so eine Weile hin und her, bis ich dann irgendwie einen Apple-Techniker mal meldete in so einer Meldeliste und meinte so, ja Leute, wisst ihr denn überhaupt warum, hat es dann mal erklärt. Der Grund war der, sie schreiben die Daten weg und warten da drauf, dass die Festplatte ihnen sagt, dass die auch wirklich geschrieben worden sind. So und erst dann können sie weitermachen und das haben die anderen Betriebssysteme halt nicht getan. Also ging das scheinbar schneller, aber tatsächlich waren die Daten halt noch nicht wirklich auf der Festplatte.
Aber diese Geschichte, das war einfach, also zum Beispiel Raw Devices unter OS X sind kaputt. Also wenn ich auf die rohe Platte zugreifen will über ein Device, das hat einfach teilweise Faktor 5 bis 15 langsamer.
Ja, jetzt haben wir die Kontroverse, wa?
Wir haben jetzt die Kontroverse und wir waren jetzt glaube ich sehr technisch. Ihr seid immer noch im Blue Moon on Fritz, es ist das Chaosradio Teil 126. Ihr habt es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, wir reden über das Betriebssystem Mac OS X und ihr könnt mitdiskutieren oder Fragen stellen oder aber sagen, diese ganzen Apple-Hinies haben alle Dinge an der Klatsche, wie ihr wollt 0331 70 97 110 zum Diskutieren, nächste Sendung da und am Telefon ist Bernd. Grüß dich Bernd. Aus Berlin. Wir warten das Thema, ich glaube da willst du was sagen, dass Mac OS nicht für alle Benutzer praktikabel ist, dass zum Beispiel Hardcore-Online-Gamer eher auf dem Windows PC arbeiten.
Ich sag mal so, die Sache ist doch folgende, gerade was die Spiele angeht, egal welches Betriebssystem man jetzt benutzt, sei es jetzt OS X oder beispielsweise Windows, für Spiele, da mag ich jetzt wahrscheinlich ein dickes Pass aufmachen, die Rechner doch sowieso nicht großartig konzipiert. Wenn man spielen will, sollte man vielleicht auch irgendwie auf eine der adäquaten Spielekonsolen zurückgreifen. Und genau das, was ihr gesagt habt, ich habe die Sendung jetzt leider nicht komplett verfolgt.
Gibt es übrigens ab morgen auch als Podcast, CTC, CDE, kann man mal reinhören, ne?
Aber genau das, was ihr eben gesagt habt, ich konnte noch ein Stück reinhören gerade, ist doch die Sache, dass beispielsweise Daten, wenn ich sie auf die Platte schreibe, unter OS X verifiziert werden, während Windows beispielsweise sich einen Teufel drum schert.
Der erzählt mir einfach nur, er schreibt irgendwas drauf, ob er es wirklich tut, kann ich nicht nachprüfen.
Ja, ganz genau. Und das ist nämlich die Sache. In dem Moment, wo ich nämlich einen Hardware-Defekt habe, entsteht ein ganz großes Problem. Und was die Datensicherheit unter Windows angeht, naja, da braucht er ja gar nicht drüber reden. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das in der Sendung auch schon rübergekommen ist. Und zwar, wenn man sich das mal anguckt, von wegen auch diese, was ja auch teilweise in der Sendung jetzt schon rübergekommen ist, die alten Vorurteile, Testplatte XY wird von OS X nicht erkannt und so weiter. Das sind ja irgendwie Märchen aus den 90er Jahren. Also ich würde jetzt irgendwie keine Testplatte, die nicht irgendwie händelbar wäre. Und obendrein darf man auch nicht vergessen, was bei Windows die Sache ist. Beispielsweise Powerpoint, irgendwelche Sachen gehen nicht oder ruckeln nicht. Ich meine, Powerpoint ist letztendlich eine Software, die irgendwie auch aus dem vorigen Jahrhundert stammt, wenn man nämlich immer versucht, irgendwie Organigramme zu erstellen. Das ist so mit das Letzte, womit man da eigentlich arbeiten kann. Man müsste im Endeffekt ein 200-seitiges Handbuch lesen, dass wenn ein Organigramm fertig ist und man irgendetwas ändern möchte, liegt man nämlich irgendwie brach da. Es sei denn, man ist wirklich der Toho-Experte und kennt sich damit wirklich all in Detail aus. Da gibt es zum Beispiel Software, die weitaus preiswerter ist. Das ist nämlich auch noch so ein Aspekt, von wegen das Windows-Software irgendwo billiger ist. Das ist einfach eine mehr. Letztendlich denke ich mal, das ist ein Tenor. Ich möchte, dass die Maschine meine Probleme löst und nicht umgekehrt. Und es kann Windows einfach nicht. Egal welches Windows man da jetzt zu raten nimmt oder installiert, das letzte System, das irgendwie was getaugt hat, war die 2000er-Version, auch was die Netzwerksfähigkeit angeht. Alles andere ist irgendwie so Kleinköchelei, nämlich das, was beispielsweise den Apple-System immer vorgehalten wurde, so die eigenen Sachen zu fördern und stabil zu halten, genau das oder den Weg geht gerade Microsoft oder Windows. Bestes Beispiel ist, versuch mal auf der Windows, in der Windows-State, sagen wir mal jetzt, Bista ein altes Office-System laufen zu lassen. Das läuft nämlich nicht. Da kannst du nämlich erst mal in das Portemonnaie greifen und richtig Geld ausgeben. Und das ist eben App-System. Also sprich... Ich habe zwei Computer. Ich habe einen Windows-Computer und ich habe einen Mac mit Power-PC, also sprich noch G5. Also sprich, die ganzen Sachen oder sage ich mal, die Handicaps, die man noch hatte. Als man Power-PCs verwendet hat, die sind ja nun obdulliert.
Wenn dir jetzt ein Freund auf dich zukommt und dich fragt, was er sich für einen Computer kaufen soll, was sagst du dann?
Ein Grün.
Ja, das Wichtigste ist erstmal, was will er damit machen? Also sprich, wenn er jetzt irgendwelche Zocker-Games machen will, okay, soll er sich eine Windows-Maschine kaufen? Wenn er damit tatsächlich arbeiten will, sprich einen schnelleren Workflow will, dann soll er sich einen Mac kaufen. Oder erst recht dann, wenn er keinen Bock hat, irgendwie Samstag Nacht irgendwelche Treiber oder irgendwelchen Mist zu installieren und obendrein noch eine Freundin hat, dann ist er mit Windows schlecht bedient.
Kompliment für die Argumentation.
Also, das ist so der Thema und deswegen die Sache auch mit den Festplatten. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass es da zwei konkurrierende Systeme gibt, wo natürlich auch mit Absicht teilweise, beispielsweise bei iTunes in neuen Windows-Versionen es Probleme gab, dass speziell die Apple-Software dann irgendwo nicht ließ. Wobei das natürlich auch doof ist, weil als die neuen iTunes-Versionen rauskamen, auf der Betriebssystemwächse bei Microsoft anstand, dass es natürlich Inkompatibilitäten gab. Das ist ja logisch. Aber zum Beispiel, die meisten Leute benutzen Photoshop zur Verwaltung oder zur Bearbeitung ihrer Fotos. Wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt, was man tatsächlich benötigt, also sprich das Wecksortieren oder Verwalten einfach von Bildern, die man mit einer einfachen Digitalkamera, die du bei Schlecker oder so gekauft hast, das macht einmal mit iPhoto und dann macht man mit Alternativprogrammen, die du in der Windows-Base bekommst, da kriegst du Nervenzusammenbruch oder sei es drum, dass du eine Foto-CD brennen möchtest, die dann nicht auf den beliebigen DVD-Spieler am Fernseher wiedergegeben wird.
Bernd, wir halten fest von deiner Akkumentation als Zusammenfassung, weil jetzt rumpelt hier auch ein bisschen in der Telefonleiste, es prüfe sich, wer sich binden will vorher, was er denn genau haben möchte.
Ja, wobei auf der anderen Seite, du musst es ja nicht mal mehr prüfen, weil du kannst ja, wenn du unbedingt drauf abkehrst, kannst du ja auf den aktuellen Mac Windows jederzeit voll betriebsfähig starten.
Und da ist der Unterschied zu einer dann für die Ewigkeit geschlossenen Ehe. Bernd, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ich danke euch und noch viel Spaß.
Chaos Radio Teil 126, ihr seid im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Wir haben noch eine knappe Stunde Zeit, reden über Mac OS, die Vor- und Nachteile, die dieses System bietet. Wir haben gerade von Tim und von Pavel vom Chaos Computer Club eine sehr ausführliche und höchst interessante Einführung in die Geschichte von dem Betriebssystem Mac OS bekommen und haben jetzt eine Menge Anrufer, die sich zu den unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen äußern werden. Eben gerade hatten wir Bernd dran, der eine doch sehr gerade ausargumentierte, flammende Rede auf den Mac gehalten hat. Jetzt am Telefon ist Peter, der gegenteiliger Meinung zu Bernd ist. Name, Peter.
Ja, hallo.
Grüß dich, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Berlin.
Welchen Rechner benutzt du?
Ich benutze so ideas. Also das geht los halt von Zahn bis über irgendwas. Also je nachdem wo ich, wo ich vor welcher Kiste ich halt im Endeffekt sitze. Also ich sag mal so, jedes System hat seine Vor- und Nachteile und Fakt ist einfach eins, meiner Meinung nach, also die letzte Version vom vom OS X halt an sich ist absoluter Schrot. Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist genauso überladen, dass es halt einfach mal, der wird nicht mehr schmal gedacht, sondern halt wirklich schmal fabriziert, beziehungsweise programmiert. Das ist absolut daneben. So viele Bugs gab es halt bei OS X, also beziehungsweise bei Mac halt noch nie.
Kannst du da mal ein Beispiel um die Ecke kommen?
Mit einem Beispiel um die Ecke kommen, zum Beispiel, ich war mal, irgendwann mal beim Kunden halt unterwegs gewesen, der hat sich ein super X- System halt geholt und super toll mit den DanceGuardian und so weiter und so fort, Problem war gewesen, dass er im Grunde genommen mit einer super tollen grafischen Oberfläche gearbeitet hat und so weiter, wollte mir erzählen, wie toll die ganze Geschichte ist. Fakt war einfach mal eingewiesen, dass zum Beispiel bei den DanceGuardian halt auf der grafischen Oberfläche halt Buttons halt da waren, die halt nur reine Dummies halt waren, die haben im Grunde genommen halt nicht wirklich eine Funktion halt ausüben. Das hab ich halt irgendwie dann mal mehr oder weniger halt in wirkliche Konsole halt dann fixen müssen und ich fand das halt einfach mal absolut grauenhaft mit wieviel, also wieso man im Grunde genommen halt einfach diese ganze Geschichte halt einfach insofern halt hyped, dass man sagt OS X und Linux und flalala.
Klang aber jetzt nicht nach einem besonders katastrophalen Fehler.
Ich hab kein Wort verstanden. DanceGuardian, keine Ahnung. Kannst du das übersetzen, Tim?
Ich noch nicht.
Okay, Peter, wir müssen noch weiter zuhören. Wir verstehen noch nicht so richtig, worum es geht.
Also ich bin der Meinung, dass zum Beispiel halt einfach mal diese OS X Geschichte an sich insofern überladen ist, dass man mehr und mehr auf die grafische Geschichte halt in Wert legt und im Endeffekt halt einfach auch mal vergisst, dass.
Du bist jetzt aus der Kommandozeilenfraktion, ja?
Ja, nein, also so will ich das auch nicht sagen. Auf keinen Fall. Ich sag mal so, jedes System, ich bin halt absolut der Meinung, dass jedes System seine Vorteile hat, aber halt auch viele Nachteile in der Entwicklung.
Da sind wir aber völlig einer Meinung. Da sind wir völlig einer Meinung. Das mag sich vielleicht jetzt alles so ein bisschen angehört haben, dass jetzt irgendwie der Macintosh das Tollste ist. Das wollten wir damit nicht sagen, aber wir wollten auf jeden Fall erst mal klar machen, es gibt eine ganze Menge Leute, die mit diesem System eine Menge coole Sachen hinkriegen und das stellt sich einfach wenig in den Weg und es ist eine Alternative. Und wie man nun das eine oder andere findet, das hängt natürlich auch immer ein bisschen davon ab, was man macht. Du hast ja XServe erwähnt, das ist Server-Anwendung, das ist definitiv eine der Schwächen von Apple, wo sie auch noch relativ neu sind in dem Markt und damit sie auch selber nicht besonders angeben. Obwohl ich da auch gute Erfahrungen gesammelt habe, aber das ist jetzt auch erstmal nicht so wichtig. Was ich sagen wollte ist, du sagtest ja eben auch so, naja, da muss ich das dann irgendwie auf der Kommandozeile fixen, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe. Ja, das geht, das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Also die Kommandozeile ist sehr ordentlich. Das ist auch ein großer Vorteil von OS X. Man hat halt dieses ganze Linux noch unten drunter. Das heißt, das ganze UNIX wollte ich sagen. Also die ganze UNIX-Umgebung und der große Vorteil ist, man hat auch eine sehr große Auswahl an Open Source-Software. Also die Open Source-Welt ist einem auch weitgehend zugänglich. Das heißt, wenn man unterwegs ist, man findet sehr viel Software, die sich vor allem unkompliziert installieren lässt. Linux hat so ein bisschen das Problem, dass man sehr viel Zeit immer noch reinstecken muss, um wirklich sein System auf der Höhe zu halten und doch sehr viel schrauben. Also Linux ist immer noch nicht unkompliziert.
Ja, das Ding ist halt einfach, da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Distributionen und von daher muss man auch viele Sachen halten.
Ja, aber es gibt keine Distribution, die einfach so funktioniert und einfach auch alles kann. Das fängt an mit den fehlenden Media-Playern unter Linux, die ich mir erstmal nachholen und eigentlich alles selber durch compilen muss, weil aus rechtlichen Gründen viele Dinge nicht gehen. Ich nutze alle drei Betriebssysteme. Ich kenne sie ganz gut und es gibt Stärken und Schwächen. Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Aber wenn man jetzt mal guckt all around, was ist jetzt aus meiner Sicht das unterm Strich für meine private Nutzung, für das Lesen von Mails?
Ich nehme halt einfach die älteren Distributionen von OS. Im Grunde genommen fand ich die älteren Versionen einfach stabiler.
Es wird nicht besser. Das gilt aber für alle Plattformen. Neulich gab es diesen netten Shootout Mac Plus von 1986, 1987 ungefähr gegen ein aktuelles AMD Doppelkernsystem. Dann hat man halt geguckt, wie lange dauert es booten, bestimmte Dinge in Word zu starten, Excel zu starten und die Dinge. Da hat halt der 20 Jahre alte Mac Plus knapp, zwar aber in allen Disziplinen eigentlich mit einem hundertstel fast an Ram und Rechenleistung war er schneller bei diesen praktischen Aufgaben.
Um das vielleicht ins Normalspräch zu übersetzen, das ist in etwa vergleichbar, wenn man ein altes Auto hat, eine Glühbirne wechseln will, machst die Motorhaube auf, wechselt die Birne fertig, wenn du ein neues Auto hast, musst du in der Werkstatt, weil sie müssen den Motor rausnehmen.
Ich habe aber auch lieber jetzt einen aktuellen Van als ein VW-Variant aus den 70er Jahren. Es kann ja sein, dass da die Zündung schneller gestartet ist, aber am Ende war der Komfort doch ein anderer.
Das ist jetzt auch wirklich extrem, also wieder so sehr viel Detail geprökelt.
Also mit der Diskussion kommen wir jetzt...
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Peter, ich verstehe das vollkommen. Das ist auch immer so eine Frage der Wahrnehmung. Sicherlich Mac OS X 3 kam mir auch ein bisschen geschmeidiger vor, aber wenn ich mir das Feature Set von der aktuellen Mac OS X Version anschaue, ich würde ja nicht wieder zurückgehen wollen. Und das sind kleine Schwankungen im Universum.
Ja und nein, also wie gesagt, ich persönlich bin der Meinung, dass das definitiv zu viel ist. Aber noch mal eine andere Geschichte, ganz am Rande in Bezug auf den Paragraph 202C. Da würde mich mal eure Meinung dazu interessieren. Ihr habt sicherlich mitgekriegt, was die letzte Zeit durch die Medien ging.
Aber wir haben nur zwei Stunden und wollen echt beim Thema bleiben, weil wenn wir da jetzt das Fass aufmachen, dann sind wir ganz unvergesslich.
Wir haben aber auch, wenn du auf die CCC-Seite guckst, direkt vorne als erstes der Disclaimer dazu. Also wir haben eine Menge, glaube ich, auch Presseerklärungen abgegeben und eigentlich eine ganz klare Meinung dazu, dass dort der Gesetzgeber...
Peter, pass auf.
ist der Gesetzgeber ziemlich...
Die Frage, die sich daraus herstellt, ist grundsätzlich...
Ich unterbreche dich genau jetzt, weil das ist eine andere Baustelle, die klären wir, aber nicht hier und nicht heute.
Gerade in Bezug auf Mac und andere Derivate, die irgendwie UNIX, Linux, ähnlich oder was auch immer... Im Grunde genommen, die Bordtools, die mit dabei sind, sind ja im Grunde genommen nach dem...
Darauf jetzt sehen aus.
eigentlich nichtig, oder?
Das steht aber nur so im Gesetz. Diejenigen, die die Gesetze gemacht haben, behaupten, sie hätten was ganz anderes gemeint, als das, was da drin steht. Das heißt, wir können nichts anderes als uns angucken, abwarten, was da am Ende bei rauskommt.
Bevor wir jetzt noch erläutern müssen, was der Paragraph 212c ist, es führt jetzt echt zu weit. Oder 202c. Peter, sorry, aber das machen wir an einer anderen Stelle, okay?
Tschüss. Ja, muss man mal einen Podcast nachschieben.
Vielleicht jetzt nur für Interesse. Kann man das in einem Halbsatz zusammenfassen, was das ist?
Verbot von Hacker Tools.
Es ist eine Gesetzesnovelle, eine sehr böse. Und wer auf www.ccc.de sieht, dass das Internet per Deklaration eine Blümchenwiese geworden ist. Und alles ist gut, weil es kann nichts mehr passieren, denn das Böse wurde jetzt endgültig verboten. Nach dem Waldsterben jetzt auch Hacker Tools.
Guten Abend Andreas.
Hallo, ich bin aus Pankow.
Grüß dich.
Und ich bin Mac User seit 1987. Angefangen mit Mac Plus.
Das war die Übermaschine, die wir gerade angesprochen haben.
Ja, ich habe auch fast alle Rechner aufgehoben, zum Glück. Ich bin jetzt aktuell bei Macbook Pro. Und was ich eigentlich nur sagen will, ist, ich arbeite im Designbereich und deshalb natürlich mit dem Mac, weil der einfach schöner aussieht und das mit dem Programm besser flutscht und die Ikonen und alles ist halt konsistent und einheitlich und nicht so wahnsinnig vielfältig wie bei Windows-Software. Das ist ja oft so, dass bei vielen Programmen haben sie eine ganz eigene Bildsprache bei den Menüs und Ikonen. Das fand ich halt immer ziemlich doof. Und die meisten Designer, die ich kenne, finden es auch doof. Und eigentlich ist es ja so, mit den neuen Dingern kann man ja eben auch mit Bootcamp Windows laufen lassen. Und gerade im Designbereich, im 3D-Bereich, da gibt es halt auf dem Mac keine professionelle Software. Und jetzt kann ich mit meinem Mac arbeiten. Und wenn ich halt ein Windows-Programm brauche, kann ich den eben als Windows-Rechner hochfahren und kann ganz prima mit Windows arbeiten. Und das flutscht wunderbar.
Welche Software meinst du dann, die du nicht benutzen kannst?
Ja, zum Beispiel Software wie Alias AutoStudio oder ProEngineer oder Cartier. So Programme aus dem Auto-Konstruktionen.
Okay, aber Maya grundsätzlich geht. Aber stimmt, die Spezialversion geht hier nicht?
Ja, also richtige Produktdesign oder Architektur, Software-Felixplanung und so. Das gibt es halt nach wie vor. Das gibt es halt nicht. Das kommt eben dann vor, dann muss ich den Rechner neu starten und eine Weile Windows ertragen. Aber es läuft eben wunderbar. Und das finde ich eigentlich eine tolle Sache.
Aber Parallels kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen. Jetzt in der letzten Version geht auch 3D ganz ordentlich. Und es ist wirklich eine echte Erleichterung, wenn man nicht umbooten muss. Und das performt ganz ordentlich und ist wunderbar. Also lohnt sich.
Also auch mit dieser 3D-Software? Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert.
Es geht erst seit zwei Wochen oder so.
Aber ich kenne das eben auch von vielen. Also ich hatte bis vor zwei Jahren hatte ich eben parallel noch ein Windows-Laptop für diese ganzen Sachen. So ein hässliches Fujitsu Siemens X-RiOS Hard-File mit einer Stunde Batterielaufzeit. Und das fällt jetzt eben alles weg. Und die meisten aus der Branche, die ich kenne, die noch vorher Windows-User waren, die haben jetzt sofort den Switch gemacht, weil die eben auch mit schönen Geräten einfach arbeiten wollen, wo alles auf Software-mäßig so locker miteinander verzahnt ist. Und was ich oft finde, ist, dass eben, wenn die Leute sagen, ja, da habe ich Bugs und Command-Zahlen-Interfaces, ich habe immer nur den Rechner aus der Packung genommen, die Software gekauft, installiert und habe nie was runtergeladen. Und ich muss echt sagen, ich hatte auch schon früher mit den Apple-Rechnern nie irgendwelche Probleme, die man auch so in Zeitschriften liest. Also ich glaube, eine Menge kommt eben so an Probleme, auch weil die Leute einfach dann eben so ein bisschen rumbasteln und nicht genau wissen, was würde sich da aus dem Netz runterladen und so.
Viren zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel, also hatte ich nie auf der Mac-Seite ein Problem damit.
Diese alte Legende, dass Macs weniger anfällig sind für Viren, also nicht Legende, das ist ja eine Tatsache, als Windows-Systeme. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit dem neuen Intel-Prozessor? Hat sich da was verändert mit der Systemsicherheit und der Systemperformance?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist noch nicht unbedingt geklärt. Grundsätzlich kann man sagen, dadurch, dass sie auf Intel gegangen sind, sind sie jetzt ein bisschen... Ach so, haben wir den Andreas noch in der Leitung? Ja, alles klar. Ja, ich würde sagen, erstmal danke.
Wir haben dich jetzt erstmal verarzelt Andreas, oder?
Ich wollte mal kurz darauf eingehen, mit der Sicherheit, weil die Frage war ja auch im Wiki. Also, es gibt ja eine lange und breite Diskussion mit Viren und generell mit Sicherheit. Wobei Sicherheit ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr weites Feld und hat auch sehr viel mit Prozessen und nicht nur so sehr mit Zuständen zu tun. Auf jeden Fall, derzeit ist es einfach so, es gibt keinen bekannten, wirklich in der Wildbahn umherstreifenden Virus für den Mac. Was eine ganz beeindruckende Zahl ist in Anbetracht der aber tausenden Viren, die es halt in der Windows Welt gibt. Das heißt aber nicht, dass es keine bekannten Sicherheitslücken gibt. Und schon gar nicht, dass es keine unbekannten Sicherheitslücken gibt. Ich bin mir sogar sehr sicher, dass es die gibt. Es kann vor allem auch eine ganze Menge geben, die noch nicht gefunden worden sind. Ob die jetzt gefunden werden und ob die dann auch entsprechend von dieser Virenszene so ausgenutzt werden und ob Apple da in der Lage ist, was dagegen zu tun, wenn es denn mal soweit ist, kann ich nicht beantworten. Tatsache ist, derzeit sieht es noch ganz gut aus. Allerdings, jetzt mit der Intel-Plattform ist die Zahl der Experten, die solche Fehler ausnutzen können, natürlich signifikant gestiegen. Weil die Leute wissen halt einfach bei Intel deutlich besser Bescheid. Der PowerPC-Prozessor, den sie vorher verwendet haben, war in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein Schutz. So wie wenn man in ein anderes Land kommt, da wird eine andere Sprache gesprochen, da kann man die Leute jetzt nicht gleich zu irgendwelchen Trickbetrügereien überreden. Und das muss ich jetzt zeigen. Auf der anderen Seite, Apple weiß, dass es sowas gibt, wie Sicherheit. Und Mac OS X hat auch in dem aktuellen System immerhin so etwas wie eine Security-Architektur, die sehr umfangreich ist. Das geht sehr weit. Schon immer gab es sowas wie einen Schlüsselbund-Manager, sodass ich alle meine Passwörter in einer verschlüsselten Datei ablegen kann. Und jedes Programm, was ich benutze, Web-Browser, Mail-Programme usw. legen die dort ab, sodass ich mit einem Schlüssel alles verschlüsseln kann und diese Datei wirklich verschlüsselt ist. Wenn ich mir einen Firefox installiere, nur mal so als Beispiel, das ist einmal so ein glorios gelobter Browser, der speichert dann die Passwörter für die Website, wenn ich sage, speichere mal in irgendeine Datei, in irgendeinem Format und ich habe keine Ahnung wo und ich habe keine Ahnung wie und vor allem habe ich keine definierte Methode darauf zuzugreifen. Mit diesem zentralen Schlüsselbund, was alle anderen Programme benutzen auf dem Mac, kann ich auch sehr gut meine eigenen Passwörter wieder nachschlagen, wenn ich es mal vergessen habe. Das ist sehr praktisch. Was aber noch viel wichtiger ist, ist, dass an der Stelle nicht nur in eine Datei geschrieben wird, sondern das Betriebssystem bietet auch das gesamte User-Interface zur Verwaltung dieser Sachen. Das heißt, das Speichern eines Schlüssels in dieses Schlüsselbund ist in jedem Programm identisch. Es verhält sich immer auf dieselbe Art und Weise. Es kommt immer derselbe Dialog und der sagt, Programm XY möchte jetzt gerne diese Information da reinschreiben. Ist das okay? Oder dieses Programm möchte es rauslesen. Ist das okay? Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte mit, bei Mac OS X ist immer sehr viel mehr drin und die Benutzung ist nämlich meistens auch drin. Die Programme vererben das automatisch.
Aber ich würde sagen, trotzdem, dass aus technischer Sicht OS X nicht per se sicherer ist als jetzt Linux oder Windows. Es ist halt nur so, dass man vielleicht vielleicht auch als Schweizer in manchen Ländern unbedenklicher unterwegs sein kann als als Amerikaner. Das ist halt auch ein ähnlicher Effekt. Man wird halt eher ignoriert. Die Bedrohung ist einfach immer noch nicht da. Aber das kann sich natürlich ändern.
Wir kommen jetzt zu Thomas. Der hat eine technische Frage. Ich glaube, die geht an die Adresse von Pavel. Name Thomas. Von wo rufst du an? Aus Hannover, grüß dich.
Ja, ich habe mal eine Frage und zwar von der anderen Seite. Und zwar von der Seite des Programmierers. Da hätte ich gerne das hier mal so ein bisschen erzählt, wie es aussieht, wie einfach der Programmierer programmieren kann. Ob zum Beispiel der UNIX-Entwickler leichter reinfindet in Mac oder der Windows-Programmierer. Also ich selber habe noch nicht mit Mac programmiert. Daher wird mich das interessieren.
Machst du das professionell?
Was professionell?
Programmieren ist irgendwie dein Broterwerb oder machst du das nebenbei?
Also momentan studiere ich es und das wird dann wohl auch mein Broterwerb werden. Genau. Ja und da interessiert mich halt hier. Ich habe hier gelesen von Developer Tools, die dabei sind, die es halt einfach machen sollen, dass man unter Mac OS X programmiert. Ja, ist es dann mehr so für Anfänger gedacht? Oder wie finden sich auch Profis zurecht? Wie kompatibel ist denn die Programmierung zu den anderen Betriebssystemen?
Ja, also zunächst einmal kann man sagen, wenn du einen Mac OS X erwirbst, entweder mit dem Rechner oder separat, dann sind die kompletten Entwicklungswerkzeuge dabei. Es fehlt nichts. Du hast die vollständige Entwicklungsumgebung, du musst nichts dazu kaufen. UNIX-typisch, vielleicht eher Windows-typisch, weil es halt eine komplette IDE ist, mit Debugger und Source-Verwaltung und so weiter.
Man hat dort halt eben den GNU-Toolchain komplett, also den GCC, aber man hat oben drauf durchaus eine ganz brauchbare, grafische IDE und auch der Debugger, der halt auch den GDB wrapped. Also das ist durchaus benutzbar, Performance-Tools.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall komplett. Es gibt da nichts, was man noch dazu kaufen muss.
Was jetzt die APIs angeht, also das war eigentlich, kann man sagen, fast eine Schwäche des Mac auch von Anfang an, oder der Vorteil, dass das alles, dass das Betriebssystem sehr viel umfasst, heißt auch, dass die API sehr, sehr mächtig ist. Das ist dann auch oft eine Hürde, also wenn man wirklich jetzt komplett nativ...
Jetzt bist du aber bei dem alten Mac.
Na, es gibt mehrere, es gibt auch, man muss sich dann erstmal entscheiden, auf welcher Ebene man unterwegs sein will und wie man programmieren will. Also es gibt auch sehr viele verschiedene Arten. Wenn man jetzt einfach nur auf der Kommando-Zeile, man kann auch ganz normal eben beliebige UNIX-Programme natürlich schreiben und benutzen. Es gibt auch X-Windows, das ist allerdings...
Ja gut, aber das ist ja nicht das, was wir haben. Du willst auch darauf hinaus, die Anwendung für den Mac, die aussehen, wie sie auf dem Mac zu sein haben.
Genau, also die Frage an mich, die Frage von mir ist auch so, diese Aquaoberfläche, wenn ich jetzt für die Aquaoberfläche programmiere, sodass meine Programme sich da auch einbinden, wie flexibel bin ich da noch im Gegensatz, also im Vergleich zu den anderen Betriebssystemen? Ob es da eine Möglichkeit gibt, dass man immer noch eine Applikation schreiben kann, die mehrere Betriebssysteme bedient.
Okay, das ist nochmal ein anderer Aspekt. Da sag ich gleich mal davor, das ist nicht so einfach. Das liegt einfach da drin, dass der wesentliche Unterschied vom Mac zu den anderen Betriebssystemen ist, dass das mit der Programmierung ganz anders geht. Das kann man jetzt als Vorteil oder als Nachteil werten. Der Nachteil ist natürlich, du hast nicht mal eben eine Anwendung, die du auf alle anderen Betriebssysteme werfen kannst. Der Vorteil ist, du kannst auch alles, was auf dem Mac existiert, was bei den anderen nicht da ist, gleich nutzen, ohne großen Aufwand zu treiben. Also ich habe, ich programmiere keine Anwendungen auf Mac, also zumindest keine GUI-Anwendungen. Ich habe nur ein bisschen damit rumgespielt. Ich kenne Leute allerdings, die das tun. Ich habe in 10 Minuten ohne eine Zeile Programmcode zu schreiben, nur mit der IDE durch das Verknüpfen der vorhandenen Funktionalitäten einen Webbrowser erstellt. Programmieren möchte ich an der Stelle nicht reden. Warum erwähne ich das? Das heißt, alles basiert zunächst einmal darauf, dass du schon so eine Grundfunktionalität hast in den sogenannten Frameworks. Und du fügst dann nur noch das hinzu, was sozusagen diese Frameworks nicht haben. Und damit hast du das ganze verhalten. Diese Anwendung hatte alles. Es hatte irgendwie einen Icon, ich habe das gestartet, dann hat es eine Menüzeile gehabt, es hat ein Fenster aufgemacht, ich konnte oben irgendwie eine URL eingeben, Return drücken und dann hat es mir die Webseite angezeigt.
Also dieses Objective, also es gibt auch, ich sag mal, zwei verschiedene Apis im Prinzip, die wichtig sind, wenn man nativ unterwegs ist, nämlich Carbon und Cocoa. Cocoa ist mehr so der Objective-C Ansatz. Das heißt, das ist schon etwas gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber auf jeden Fall auch durchaus mächtig, aber wie gesagt, gewöhnungsbedürftig. Während Carbon dieselbe Funktion, oder nicht die, ja doch den Großteil der Funktionalität auch bereitstellt, der teilweise unten drunter auch sitzt und mehr so eine klassische C Funktionsapi ist. Aber beide sind so, wo man nicht rumkommt, ist wirklich, ja, sich durch Tausende von Api-Funktionen erst mal zumindest sich drauf zu schaffen, zu wissen, dass es sie gibt. Wenn man einmal, wenn man das Ganze im Griff haben will. Also es ist schon so, dass die Lernkurve für Mac-Programmierung durchaus nicht gering ist. Aber das gilt, ich meine, wenn man sich.NET oder die Win32-Api oder gar irgendwie jetzt Programme für KDE oder GNOME schreiben will, ist das nicht viel anders. Die sind aber, ja.
Darf ich dir wieder schreiben? Also, ich will es nochmal von der anderen Seite aufrollen. Das ist vor allem erstmal eine Frage der Programmiersprachen. Apple setzt ganz erheblich auf eine Programmiersprache, die sie mal selbst erfunden haben, nämlich Objective-C. Das ist eine Erweiterung der Programmiersprache C um objektorientierte Features, aber nicht so wie C++ das macht, sondern dort wurde im Wesentlichen die Funktionalität von Smalltalk kopiert. Das ist so ein Klassiker der objektorientierten Programmiersprachen. Ob das denn gut ist oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt, ein Großteil der Anwendungen, die auf Mac kommen, sind in dieser Programmiersprache programmiert. Und es sind meistens die, die sich besonders elegant bedienen lassen. Dieses Carbon-Interface, was Paul erwähnt hat, das ist im Prinzip der Ballast von dem alten Mac OS. Das ist die alte Programmierung. Damit kann man dann auch mit C++ programmieren. Aber es gibt mittlerweile auch Möglichkeiten, mit Python vollständige Mac-Anwendungen zu machen. Und ich glaube, für Ruby gibt es mittlerweile auch etwas. Also es gibt schon eine gewisse Auswahl. Aber, um realistisch zu sein, wenn man coole Anwendungen machen will, dann ist eigentlich der Weg, den man gehen will, mit Objective-C zu arbeiten. Das mag nicht jeder. Und das ist auch noch mal so eine Diskussion für sich, ob es wertvoll ist, sozusagen da so eine Einschränkung in der Wahl der Programmiersprachen zu haben. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man eben mit Objective-C, mit diesen Frameworks, wenn man wirklich mit dem Standard Cocoa API programmiert, sehr schnell, sehr einfach Anwendungen machen, weil man eben nicht 1000 APIs kennen muss.
Also die, ich kann nur... Was?
Warte mal, Thomas, kannst du bis hierhin folgen? Ja klar. Alles klar, fantastisch. Für alle anderen, die jetzt immer denken, was ist hier API, Gnu, GUI-Anwendung, IDE, wie auch immer, das ist das Chaos Radio, das hört ihr auf Fritz, es ist Teil 126, wir reden über Mac OS.
Kann ich noch was sagen?
Eins noch, weil wir stehen kurz vor der Tür der Nachrichten.
Ich wollte kurz noch was zusammenfassen, wenn ich kann. Also kann man quasi sagen, wenn man Betriebssystem übergreifend programmieren will, muss man sich an die vorhandenen Sachen halten, sowas wie Java, STK und solche, also verschiedene Sachen, die sowieso unter allen drei laufen.
Ja, Java geht gut, GTK geht gut.
Aber wenn man sowas wie so ein Betriebssystem übergreifender API, dass die integriert wird in diese Aqua-Oberfläche, dass zum Beispiel die Aqua-Oberfläche sagt, ich erkenne diese API an und übersetze das quasi in das Äquivalent, sodass es in diesen Stil mit hineinpasst, den ich für meinen Desktop angelegt habe, das gibt es noch nicht.
Nein, in der Form, wie...
Weil das wäre ja schön, so ein Standard für alle Betriebssysteme zu haben.
Ja, aber davon träumen sie ja nun schon alle lange Zeit. Und was ist bisher dabei rausgekommen?
Aber ich kann vielleicht einen Satz zum Abschluss noch, wie das Leben so als Mac-Programmierer ist. Also man bewegt sich in einer recht großen Nische. Und man, ja, da kann man, weil es eben, es gibt nicht so viele Mac-Programmierer wie für die anderen Plattformen. Das heißt, man kann sich das da in der Nische auch ganz gemütlich machen, wenn man da reingeht. Und wie gesagt, 6% installierte Basis. Das ist enorm, wenn man sich überlegt, dass es sich nur um die Geräte eines Herstellers handelt. Das ist schon ziemlich viel, was man da an Leuten erreichen kann.
Dann wünschen wir dir hiermit, lieber Thomas in Hannover, das Beste für deine berufliche Zukunft. Drücken die Daumen, dass das toll wird. Und solltest du den zweiten Porsche kaufen, fahren wir bitte einmal mit Probe.
Ja, Dankeschön.
Schönen Abend noch.
Was ist das? Tagsüber Fußball und Abends Konzerte. Fritz präsentiert den Berle Cup in Spremberg.
Tagsüber mit einem Fußballturnier. Mit dabei ist das Fritz-Sockeateam.
Und ab 19 Uhr mit Michme.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Der Perle Cup.
Veranstaltet vom offenen Jugendtreff ASF. Kommenden Samstag in Spremberg.
Das schönste am Sommer in der Lausitz.
Und das hört man.
23.33 Fritz-Info.
Ein weiteres Team steigt bei der Tour de France aus. Der französische Rennstall Konfedes hört auf, weil einer seiner Fahrer, der Italiener Christian Morini, positiv aufs Testoteron getestet wurde. Der 34-Jährige wurde heute kurz nach der Ziele-Einfahrt verhaftet. Und vor wenigen Minuten wurde bekannt, dass der Träger des gelben Trikots Michael Rasmussen die Tour de France verlässt. Weitere Einzelheiten sind noch nicht bekannt. Mehr dazu in einer Stunde und morgen früh ausführlich bei den Radio-Fritzern. Die vermeintliche Entführung eines deutschen Journalisten in Afghanistan hat für Verwirrung gesorgt. Jetzt scheint klar, es handelt sich um einen dänischen Reporter afghanischer Abstammung. Der Mann konnte den Geise, den man in letzter Minute entkommen. Im Streit um mehr Geld haben die Lokführer mit ihrer Urabstimmung begonnen. Die Gewerkschaft rechnet damit, dass ihre Mitglieder mit großer Mehrheit für einen Streik stimmen. Seit heute bekämpfen sich beide Seiten auch vor Gericht. Die Bahn will Streiks verbieten lassen. Die Lokführer gehen gegen Einschüchterungsversuche der Bahn vor. Der FC Bayern München hat zum siebten Mal das Finale um den Liga-Pokal erreicht. Der Rekord-Champion besiegt im Halbfinale den ersatzgeschwächten deutschen Meister VfB Stuttgart mit 2 zu 0. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring, Dreik Spree auch Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Königsbüsterhausen und dem Schönefelder Kreuz gibt es Gefahr durch eine ungesicherte Unfallstelle. Der linke Fahrstreifen ist blockiert und es sind Personen auf der Fahrbahn. Und A13 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Dresden. Zwischen Ruhland und Ortrand ein schwerer Unfall. Die linke Spur ist gesperrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
2 Sprechstunden.
Die Beatstacks cut off the top. Fritz, Chaos Radio hört ihr Teil 126. Es geht heute um Mac OS X. Im Studio sind immer noch Tim und Pavel vom Chaos Computer Club und am Telefon ist Ralf aus Chemnitz. Grüß dich Ralf.
Ja, also noch ein kurzer Vorbemerkung zum Vorredner. Es gibt da so was plattformübergreifendes. Das ist das QT, was beides auch ist für das KDE. Das gibt es ja auch für Mac OS, soweit ich weiß. Und das wird auch ganz gut funktionieren.
Ja, soll ich mich dazu äußern? Aber das Problem ist, es ist ein Dilemma. Wenn etwas cross-plattform ist, dann muss es sozusagen überall genauso funktionieren. Und das schließt aus, dass etwas, was irgendwo viel besser funktionieren könnte, besser funktioniert. Und an der Stelle bist du immer beschränkt. Software, die halt damit programmiert ist, also da gibt es ein gutes Beispiel, Google Earth, die verwenden dieses QT. Das User-Interface auf dem Mac von Google Earth ist einfach mal zum reiern. Also es ist wirklich richtig total scheiße und schlecht und mies und wirklich wie die schlechteste Windows-Software, die ich mir vorstellen kann. Und das erkaufen die sich damit. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die da wirklich einen Vorteil von haben.
Naja, es läuft immerhin. Also es ist...
Ja, es läuft, es zeigt was an, aber dafür brauchst du kein User-Interface. Ich meine, das ist eine Erde, ja, da guckt man drauf. Aber sobald du mal versuchst, da irgendwie was einzugeben, wenn man nicht mal Cut und Paste funktioniert, dazuverlässig.
Ja, in Firefox auch nicht, übrigens.
Ja, das ist auch genau derselbe Kram.
Okay, wir stellen auch hier fest, der Teufel steckt im Detail. Ralf, du hast noch eine Bemerkung zur Qualität bei Mac.
Ja, nicht, nicht zum Mac, sondern so in letzter Zeit. Also gibt es so bei Sicherheitsupdates oder irgendwelchen Updates generell, so 10.4.9 oder 10.4.10, da gab es ganz schöne Probleme. Also ich hatte den letzten fast Probleme und da hat es mir mein Mac fast ganz zerschossen. Also ich konnte dann nur noch von der Kommandoteile aus das vorherige Update einspielen, weil überhaupt keine Oberfläche mehr hochkam. Da war irgendwas, weiß ich nicht, Keychainmanager, irgendwelche Bibliotheken kaputt. Da kamen irgendwelche, der dynamische Linker, da hat irgendwelche Fehler gebracht. Also das sind irgendwelche Fehler, das finde ich schon irgendwie bedenklich. Aber ansonsten bin ich auch zwar auch sehr begeistert und merke, diese Qualität, der Update, da muss Apple, finde ich, noch ein bisschen mehr tun.
Da merkt man, dass die halt auch nur mit Wasser kochen.
Na, ich habe das jetzt gelesen, die kochen auch nur mit Wasser, aber mit sehr teuren.
Wobei, also ich muss sagen, gut, ich habe jetzt nur meine empirische ein Jahr Benutzer-Erfahrung und so irgendwelche größeren Katastrophen sind mir jetzt erspart geblieben. Ich bin so ein Intensivnutzer. Also bei mir ist das Ding 16 Stunden am Tag, sieben Tage in der Woche in Betrieb und ist eigentlich 24 Stunden am Tag in meiner Nähe. Das führe ich immer, also MacBook Pro halt. Und meistens halten, also Laptops halten wegen dieser Intensivnutzung bei mir ungefähr ein Jahr. Danach sind sie einfach durch. Die Tasten sind abgewetzt und irgendwie das klappert alles und dann kann man es zwar noch benutzen. Und bislang hält er. Also ja, ein paar Schrauben sind schon ab und so und die Tastatur glänzt auch schon ganz verdächtig, aber ansonsten. Und mit den Software-Updates muss ich sagen, das hat bisher problemlos funktioniert. Ich bin da auch mal misstrauisch, weil heutzutage schiebt einem ja jeder fast jeden Tag möchte sich irgendetwas updaten auf dem Rechner, irgendwie mal der Browser, mal irgendeine Anwendung, mal das Betriebssystem und so richtig wohl fühlt man sich natürlich nicht dabei, weil jedes Mal ist es eigentlich eine neue Software, die man hat. Und ja.
Das finde ich auch so ein bisschen manko, was Apple eben noch hat, finde ich, also bei Mac OS. Was ansonsten ja eigentlich sehr gut ist, aber bei Windows, da gibt es diesen abgesicherten Modus, wenn irgendwas zerschlossen ist, dann kann ich immer noch diesen abgesicherten Modus starten oder...
Gibt es auch beim Mac OS Shift drücken?
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt so ein Update zum Beispiel eingespielt habe, das habe ich ja probiert gehabt, und da kam ja gar keine grafische Oberfläche mehr zu den Standen. Und da habe ich auch Shift und alle möglichen Tasten, die es da gibt, gedrückt, da kam nie wieder eine grafische Oberfläche.
Wobei das jetzt schon nach einem sehr individuellen Problem klingt.
Also beim Mac gibt es aber eigentlich mehr Möglichkeiten, sich also im Katastrophenfall angefangen von der mitgelieferten Rettungs-CD zu booten, wo man dann Zugriff hat, bis darüber, dass man das System im Target-Mode, also jetzt bei den Laptops laufen lassen kann, und von draußen auf die Festplatte zugreifen, über Firewire bis hin. Das Beste ist, was halt bei Mac viel, bei OS X viel besser funktioniert als unter Windows, dass ich von einer Kopie meiner Festplatte einfach starten kann, wenn ich sie extern dranhänge, ohne dass ich was tun muss. Das heißt, das Geheimnis, wenn man sowas verhindern will, beispielsweise Super Duper nehmen, einmal in der Woche einen Backup ziehen, und dann kann ich, wenn irgendwas passiert, einfach sogar von diesem Backup direkt booten und das wieder zurückspielen. Also eigentlich ist es einfacher, im Katastrophenfall wieder mit Mac klarzukommen.
Und falls euch das jetzt komplett zu viel ist, Tim, es gibt auch von dieser Sendung einen Podcast, wo man das alles noch mal in Ruhe nachhören kann. Und den gibt es irgendwie im Laufe der nächsten Tage, oder? Ja, und den findet man unter ccc.de.
Unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
Ja, wie dem auch sei. Ralf, dir noch einen schönen Abend im Chemnitz. chaosradio.ccc.de Aber wenn man ccc, ne, kommt man nicht, aber...
Einfach bei googelt Chaosradio eingeben.
Oder du hast einen Bookmark.
Ja, oder was auch immer.
Mac OS X ist das eigentliche Thema dieser heutigen Sendung von Chaosradio 326. Wir haben jetzt die verschiedensten Aspekte schon beleuchtet von der Wiederherstellung des Systems, über die unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten der Programmierung bis hin zur eigentlichen Geschichte des Betriebssystems. Haben auch die Nachteile, glaube ich, in ziemlicher Ausführlichkeit behandelt. Aber es gibt noch ein paar Aspekte, die wir auf jeden Fall noch in diese Sendung packen sollten, weil sie gehören dazu.
Man könnte da so viel darüber erzählen. Mit diesen zwei Stunden kommen wir da hinten und vorne nicht zur Rande. Aber es gibt ein paar interessante Entwicklungen.
Es gibt eine neue Plattform, auf der OS X läuft.
Genau, es gibt mehrere neue Plattformen. Genau genommen ist es nur eine, du hast recht. Also Apple hat ja vor einigen Monaten neue Systeme vorgestellt, die keine Macs sind, abgesehen von den iPods. iPods gibt es ja schon länger. Aber Anfang des Jahres kamen Apple TV dazu. Wobei Apple TV eigentlich auch nichts anderes als ein abgespeckter Macintosh ist. Also eigentlich ist das so ein Mac Mini. Wobei man nicht, also nicht, ja Fern, also man kann ihn in die Ferne sehen, aber man sieht nicht das, was wir unter Fernsehen verstehen, sondern man sieht halt seine eigenen Movies, die man untergeladen oder gedownloadet oder gekauft oder per Podcast abonniert hat. Und auch da läuft Mac OS X drauf. Gut, das überrascht nicht, weil das ist im Herzen eigentlich ein Mac, aber zeigt schon mal, dass Apple da einen anderen Weg gehen wollte. Und jetzt vor ein paar Wochen ist das iPhone vorgestellt worden, ein Telefon und auch dieses Telefon läuft unter, naja, wie sie sagen, OS X oder OS X. Ich weiß gar nicht, haben sie OS X oder OS X gesagt. Ich glaube, er sagt OS X. Interessanterweise heißt es halt nur noch OS X und der Mac ist weg, weil es ist ja kein Mac, denn ein Mac ist sozusagen ein Computer, den man irgendwie durch die Gegend trägt, aber kein Telefon. Und das iPhone ist nur ein Telefon, hat auch keinen Intel Prozessor wie die Desktop-Systeme und die Laptops, sondern hat so einen typischen Spezialprozessor, der in solchen Geräten immer zu finden ist. Aber dort läuft eben im Herzen dieselbe Software. Die Oberfläche sieht allerdings total anders aus. Sehr interessant zu sehen, dass Apple es geschafft hat, ihr ein Betriebssystem so weit skalieren zu lassen, dass es eben sowohl große, dicke, fette Desktop-Maschinen und Server bedienen kann, als eben auch Telefone.
Wir haben vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, du hast so ein Ding schon in der Hand gehabt. Wir reden jetzt nicht über Bilder, die man im Internet, im Fernsehen gesehen hat. Du hattest das Ding wirklich dabei.
Ich hatte es kurz in Bedienung. Ist der Hammer. Also ich denke, das Gerät wird einschlagen wie eine Bombe.
Obwohl es so viel Negativkritik gibt von wegen, zerkratzte Oberfläche und das läuft nur irgendwie mit dem, mit einem speziellen Provider. Es ist irgendwie so und so teuer. Du musst die Software von Dingens nutzen.
Das ist genau so.
Weißt du, wenn ich jetzt losgehe, mir ein Telefon von Firma, Telefonmüller kaufe, schiebe ich irgendeine SIM-Karte hinten rein und es funktioniert.
Die Leute wollen ja nicht SIM-Karten in ihre Telefone reinschieben, sondern sie wollen ja telefonieren. Und sie wollen ja auch nicht irgendwie... Eigentlich ist es ihnen vollkommen egal, ob sie nun bei Vodafone oder T-Mobile sind, sondern sie wollen da, wo sie einfach am wenigsten genervt werden. Das heißt, die große Frage ist, ist der Tarif, mit dem das Gerät auf den Markt kommt, okay oder nicht? Dann ist den Leuten völlig Schnurzpipp, egal, welches Logo da unter Umständen irgendwo noch mal links in der Ecke steht. Hauptsache, sie haben eine Telefonnummer und sie können anrufen und es funktioniert. Das ist eben das, was auch viele Leute nicht begreifen. Wenn das iPhone vorgestellt wurde, kann man gleich so, na ja, und es hat dies nicht und es hat das nicht und es hat dies nicht und das nicht. Ich hab mir das immer so durchgelesen und das sind so Sachen, wo einfach niemand jemand schreit. Aber dass das Ding einfach mal sowas kann wie telefonieren, das halte ich schon mal für einen großen Fortschritt.
Telefonieren kann mein Telefon auch.
Ja, meins nicht. Soweit würde ich nicht gehen, dass dieses Telefon mir wirklich das Telefonieren leicht macht. Dieses Telefon, soll ich mal über meinen Telefon ranten?
Ich auch, ich auch.
Das ist so scheiße, das ist so scheiße, es ist noch nicht mal in einer Lage, in zwei unterschiedlichen Programmen dieselbe Uhrzeit anzuzeigen.
Es ist ja auch keine Uhr, es ist ja auch ein Telefon.
Ja, aber ich meine eine Uhr. Jeder verwendet sein, man trägt heute keine Armanduhr mehr, weil man hat ein Handy. Das ist so, Leute benutzen die Uhr auf ihrem Telefon, das hat sogar Nokia begriffen. Aber wie man zwei Programme mit derselben Uhrzeit ausstattet, das scheint denen komplett fern zu sein.
Wir hatten mal einen Blue Moon zum Thema Mobiltelefon und Nutzung und da stellt sich heraus, die Leute benutzen auch keine Wecker mehr. Weil natürlich hast du dein Telefon mit einem Wecker drin. Was waren denn das für Applikationen beim iPhone, wo ihr Leute gesagt habt, das hat es nicht, das hätte ich gerne, wo du sagst, brauchst nicht oder unwichtig?
Der erste Schrei war nach UMTS. Das halte ich persönlich für kein besonders wichtiges Thema. Was die Leute eigentlich haben wollen, ist schnelles Internet. Aber schnelles Internet kann man auch mit Edge bekommen. Kurz zum Hintergrund. Telefon ist ein reines GSM-Telefon. Man kann Daten über einen Standard, der heißt Edge. Edge ist etwas, was sich derzeit noch im Ausbau befindet. Vodafone zum Beispiel führt jetzt ein Megabit Datenübertragung über Edge ein. Das sollte eigentlich jedem reichen. Keine Ahnung, ob das so kommen wird, oder ob sie nicht vielleicht doch schon UMTS einbauen. Das ist nicht das, worum sich das iPhone kümmert. Das iPhone räumt einfach mit den Problemen auf, die andere Telefone haben. Dass man sie nicht einfach benutzen kann. Ich bin nun wirklich... Gut, ich bin vielleicht doof, aber nicht blöd. Ich arbeite seit 20 Jahren mit Computern, aber mein Telefon kann ich nicht bedienen. Dieses Gerät ist nicht zu benutzen. Zwölf Untermenüs, um eine Sache einzustellen, muss ich an drei verschiedenen Orten, und ich habe es danach sofort wieder vergessen. Es geht einfach nicht, es ist nicht benutzbar.
Du hast da gerade irgendwie so ein Nokia High-End-Modell.
Latest and greatest, super teuer.
Aber mein Sony Ericsson P990i ist auch die komplette Katastrophe. Die Hardware ist in Ordnung, aber die Software ist einfach ganz, ganz schlimm. Es ist so schlimm, dass man... Telefonieren geht gerade eben, aber eigentlich schlechter als bei einem Telefon von vor 5 oder 10 Jahren. Und alles andere. Ich meine, ich verstehe auch nicht, wie große Firmen, die zig Millionen in die Entwicklung stecken, in der Lage sind, so zu versagen. Ich meine, das fängt damit an. Dieses Telefon hat 90 MB RAM. Nach dem Booten belegt das Betriebssystem 80 MB. Das heißt, ich habe noch irgendwie nach dem Booten, und das Booten dauert 1, 5 Minuten ungefähr von diesem Telefon, was schon mal eine Katastrophe für sich ist. Sobald ich eine Anwendung starte, sind die restlichen 10 MB auch weg, sodass wenn ich etwa in einer Mail... Gut, wenn ich...
Wir kommen jetzt ein bisschen vom Thema weg, glaube ich.
Du hast sonst 5 Minuten. Also ein Rent will ich noch. Ich habe das Ding, weil es hat auch WLAN natürlich, weil ich dachte, gut, jetzt kann ich dann hier demnächst meine Mails lesen. Und dann platzte, aber nachdem ich halt meinen Account eingerichtet habe, weil offenbar meine Mailfolder zu groß sind, schaffte es noch nicht mehr, die Header runterzuladen. Also das Telefon, nachdem ich auf meine Mail zugreifen wollte, war unbenutzbar, bootete nicht mehr. Ich musste es komplett löschen. So, das war das erste Ding. Denn wenn man irgendwo einen Link anklickt, dann versucht er, den Browser zu öffnen, hat aber keinen Speicher mehr, weil keine zwei Programme gleichzeitig laufen könnten. Ansonsten vergisst man das Wireless auszumachen, ist die Batterie in zwei Stunden leer und nur solche Dinge. Also es ist, ich könnte jetzt minutenlang noch, aber es ist faszinierend, wie schlecht einfach heutige sogenannte, naja, wie heißt diese Klasse von Telefons? Man nennt sie Smartphones, aber leider sind sie nicht smart. Also wie schlecht Smartphones sind. Ich bin gespannt aufs iPhone. Ich hatte es noch nicht in der Hand. So, aber was schon mal ganz gut klingt, ist, dass die Oberfläche schnell ist und snappy, wie man sagt, funktioniert und einfach man ein gutes Erlebnis hat. Also ich bin gespannt.
Es ist furchtbar sexy. Aber was das eigentlich Wichtige an dem iPhone ist, erstens dadurch, dass da halt OS X drauf ist, verspricht es noch viele Überraschungen, was gute Anwendungen betrifft. Und das, was da bisher drauf ist, funktioniert einfach sagenhaft gut. Und das andere Ding, was viele Leute nicht sehen und was auch sozusagen dieser Ruf nach, ich will meinen Provider wechseln, komplett ausschaltet, es ist das erste Telefon mit Internet. Und zwar nicht das erste Telefon, das Internet könnte, sondern das erste Telefon, was, wenn ich es in Betrieb nehme, auf jeden Fall kostenlos Internet hat. Und die Programmierung für, also wer Interesse hat, für das iPhone zu entwickeln, ist quasi gezwungen, das Web gebunden zu machen. Was erstmal alle natürlich sehr enttäuscht hat, weil die wollen natürlich auf das Gerät drauf. Das hält aber Apple erstmal zu, aus vielen nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Und haben halt gesagt, na ja, ihr könnt aber hier über das Web rangehen. Und wir haben da so ein paar Hooks eingebaut, sodass ihr das auch so aussehen lassen könnt, als wäre es eine richtig schicke iPhone-Anwendung. Also mit diesem ganzen Eyecandy, den sie hier drauf haben und diese Bedienungselemente kann man halt auch alle verwenden. Und na ja, es hat eine Woche gedauert oder ein paar Tage eigentlich nur gedauert. Und diese ganzen neuen Web 2.0-Dienste, die ja so super populär sind, was weiß ich, Flickr und so weiter, To-Do-Listen, Manager, machen halt jetzt einfach ihre speziellen Interfaces fürs iPhone, was sich relativ einfach machen lässt. Und ja, dieses Gerät existiert seit zwei Wochen und es gibt wahrscheinlich jetzt schon mehr gut zu benutzende sinnvolle Anwendungen, als auf all diesen Nokia, Motorola und Sony Ericsson-Telefonen in den letzten zehn Jahren insgesamt. Und das ist, Apple macht sich sozusagen gerade auf, allen ganz gehörig den Arsch zu versohlen.
Ich bin gespannt. Ich mein, muss natürlich auch sagen, bei allem netten Nutzererlebnis, es ist natürlich, Apple ist eine Firma, die auch an vielen Stellen doch den Daumen draufhält. Es ist eine geschlossene, proprietäre Plattform. Das Open Source geht bei Apple nur bis zu einem bestimmten Grad. Also da gibt es, also Apple und Open Source ist auch eine lange kontroverse Geschichte, die wir jetzt hier nicht ausbreiten wollen. Aber das muss auf jeden Fall noch erwähnt sein, dass natürlich man auch viele Dinge durchaus misstrauisch beäugen kann und muss. Und dass ich mir jetzt trotz allem, also auch so schön Mac OS ist, ich möchte weder auf Linux noch auf Windows verzichten müssen. Ich finde es gut, dass es diese drei Plattformen gibt. Ich nutze sie alle, aber ich nutze am meisten OS X.
Wo wir gerade bei Telefonen sind, muss man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen. Hier im Chat kommt das natürlich auch gleich wieder auf. Es gibt ja noch ein anderes interessantes Telefonprojekt, was diesen Aspekt der freien Software berücksichtigt. Das OpenMoco Projekt, das ist in aller Munde. Das ist allerdings ein Projekt, was noch sehr in den Entwicklerschuhen steht. Also derzeit gibt es zwar Telefone zu kaufen, aber eigentlich nur für Entwickler. Und wenn man sich die Software anschaut, die da draufläuft, das ist auch wirklich nicht für den End-User zumutbar. Trotzdem, das ist das erste Telefon, was wirklich vollständigen Zugriff auf alles macht. Und an der Stelle hat man im Prinzip einen direkten Vergleich. Man hat die Linux-Welt sozusagen, aber auch mit ihrem ganzen Credo in diesem einen Device zunächst einmal nur. Aber das ist eine offene Plattform, da könnten also auch noch andere kommen. Wird aber noch ein bisschen dauern. Auf der anderen Seite dieser Gegenpol mit dem iPhone, das irgendwie mit Sweet Eyecandy daherkommt und auch wirklich mit Features, die mit anderen nicht drin sind. Aber wenn man dann eben das User-Interface vergleicht, zeigt sich eben, wie diese drei Welten, Windows, der Mac und Linux, auch vollständig andere Herangehensweisen haben, wie man mit dem Computer arbeitet. Windows, das ist so diese Bürokratenwirtschaftswelt mit ihren klaren Rastern und Linien und Kästchen und die einfach es gewohnt sind, auf lange Tabellen zu starren. Bei Linux ist es einfach dieses Arkane, auch dieser Spaß, sage ich noch nicht mal im Negativen, also auch dieser Spaß an der Technik selber, die dann aber auch an allen Stellen rausquillt. Und diese Mac-Domäne ist eben einfach dieses, ich habe keinen Bock, mich mit der Technik rumzuschlagen, ich möchte einfach, dass es funktioniert und es soll auch noch schick aussehen. Und das sind, glaube ich, so die großen drei Marktsegmente, die heute Computer überhaupt bedienen.
Und das ist ein wunderbares Schlusswort, auch von Tim und Pavel vom Chaos Computer Club zu diesem heutigen Thema. Mac OS X, 10, 10, ja X, 10, 10.
War das schon Schluss oder was?
Schulz jetzt, das war das Chaos Radio 126, als Podcast nachzuhören unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Wenn ihr mehr von diesen Jungs wissen wollt, wenn ihr euch mal angucken wollt, was der Chaos Computer Club eigentlich macht, 8. bis 12. August das Camp in Niederfino, in der Nähe von Eberswalde. Ich haue es immer durcheinander. Na Schnoppel, auf jeden Fall bei Eberswalde, Finofort, Flughafen, großartige Geschichte, 8. bis 12. August. Mehr dann online unter entweder chaosradio.ccc.de oder unter fritz.de. Hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Martin Petersdorf und dem Nightfly. Wir sagen Tschüss, macht's gut und fass dich in die Steckdose.
Und voller Demut legt ich meine Schürze wieder. Und schließlich kriech ich und dann grill, um mich herum wird alles still.
Hallo, abreiten.